Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal
20 Euro Gutschein
Noch bis 31.12
So, heute machen wir den richtigen, guck mal, heute machen wir den richtigen Hammer Sellout
Mehr Sellout kannst du eigentlich gar nicht machen
Oh hier, 20 Euro Gutschein noch bis 31.12
Rakete Sparkle Stonks
Also
Nur für neue Kunden, ja gut, das schreibe ich jetzt aber nicht im Titel
Das wird ein bisschen lang, ich kann ja immer ganzen Text dahinschreiben
Ähm, ne, aber was du machen kannst ist
Auch wenn mir gesagt wurde, ich soll das nicht explizit bewerben
Aber ich erwähne mal nur, dass es eine Möglichkeit ist
Man kann sich natürlich einen neuen Account erstellen
Das ist kein Ding, das funktioniert
Darf ich aber nicht so laut sagen
Hab ich gesagt, soll ich nicht so, soll ich nicht so sehr bewerben, dass man einfach neue Accounts machen kann
Nötig, wir würden nie Fake Accounts erstellen und wir laden uns über Torrent auch nur Linux Distributionen runter
Wir sind ja hier, super, ein korrekter christlicher Weihnachtstream
Hier passiert nichts komisches, was irgendwie nicht korrekt ist
Was soll ich wiederholen?
Dass ich Arch Linux verwende, ich verwende Arch Linux übrigens
Weiß nicht, ob ich das schon erwähnt habe, Mancharo mit I3
So, also ich zeige euch mal, wo wir gestern stehen geblieben sind
Wir sind gestern stehen geblieben bei der Poggers App
Also was wir gestern gemacht haben ist, ich habe Svelte gelernt
Svelte ist ein JavaScript Framework ohne ein wirkliches JavaScript Framework zu sein
So wie ich das verstanden habe und so wie sich das für mich darstellt
Ist das ein JavaScript Compiler, der quasi ähnlichen Komfort bietet wie die üblichen JavaScript Framework
Von Vue, React, Angular, was es da nicht alles gibt
Alter, kennt noch einer so die Oldschool Sachen?
Kennt noch den mal Knockout, Ember oder wie hieß das andere? Backend?
Nee, wie hieß das? Wie hieß dieses allererste größere Jahr, was hier nicht Backend?
Wie hieß das denn? Backbone, Backbone.js
Kennt dieses Oldschool Zeug noch irgendjemand?
Das war richtiger Rotz alles
Wobei ich ehrlich gesagt da nichts Großartiges drin gemacht habe
Ich bin nie glücklich, dass ich mich klarkomme
Ich habe mir bei Udemy einen Ember Kurs gekauft und habe das durchgemacht
Und habe festgestellt, meine Güte, das ist halt kompliziert
Ember ist von Leuten, die auch was mit Ruby und Rails zu tun haben
Das merkt man an vielen Stellen, aber es ist viel komplizierter
Rails ist easy, ich glaube Rails ist das einfachste Web Framework, was man überhaupt verwenden kann
Aber keiner kann Ruby heutzutage
Und nur Ruby lernen jetzt für Rails keine Ahnung
Das ist glaube ich nicht mehr so das
Ups, der hat es nicht gehört
Imagine Python und Rails, es gibt so Dinger ja
Die haben halt Django mit Dingern und Admin Interface
Lohnt es sich heutzutage noch Ruby fürs Backend zu lernen?
Ganz ehrlich eigentlich nicht
Ich finde zwar Rails ist wie gesagt das eines der besten und einfachsten Web Frameworks, die es gibt
Aber mit Ruby, also es sei denn du verdienst damit Geld
Ihr habt eine Legacy App, die in Ruby und Rails ist
Und du sollst die Betreuung, du kriegst da dick Stonks für und Kohle
Dann sieht das ja schon wieder anders aus
Aber jetzt neu anfangen, ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht ob sich das lohnt
Man muss dazu sagen, ja ich denke Rails ist nach wie vor das beste oder einfachste Web Framework
Aber Ruby ist halt verschenkt irgendwo heutzutage großartig Ruby zu lernen
Was gibt es noch großartig in Ruby wofür sich das lohnt? Es gibt eigentlich nur Rails
So 2000 bis 2010 rum war das noch so ein bisschen ein Wettbewerb zwischen Ruby und Python
Es gab sehr viele richtig geile Libraries in Ruby, die zum größten Teil verwaist sind heute
Also ich denke Ruby zu lernen ist heutzutage ein bisschen verschenkt
Auch wenn es meine Laber C Sharp meine absolut Lieblingsprogrammiersprache ist
Leider ist das, es ist aus meiner Sicht halt so, man muss sich das jetzt auch nicht schönreden
Also ich finde es sinnvoller was zu lernen womit man halt auch auf lange Sicht was anfangen kann
Leute ich mach mal kurz die Musik aus, haben wir uns jetzt lange genug angehört
Mach mal ein bisschen Mario Kart oder sowas an
Das Hauptmenü muss man jetzt nicht anhören, exellent
Ja wo war ich denn jetzt gerade dabei?
Ja also ich denke es ist sinnvoller, wenn man schon mit Programmiersprachen anfängt dann irgendwas zu nehmen
Also gerade auch wenn es um Webentwicklung, Backendgeschichten geht gerade mit irgendwas anzufangen wo man auch langfristig was anfangen kann
Gibt es ja, ich meine das offensichtlich ist Javascript
Das Javascript ist glaube ich aktuell die universalste Programmiersprache die man lernen kann
Javascript kannst du im Frontend verwenden, also im Browser
Javascript kannst du im Backend verwenden und du kannst Mobile Apps damit machen
Also ich denke mal das universalste Package, wenn du einfach nur zum Einstieg was lernen willst womit du potentiell alles machen kannst was es gibt
Außer vielleicht richtig krasse Low-Level Sachen, also du wirst wahrscheinlich keinen Bootloader in Javascript programmieren
Weil das kommt drauf an, wenn es in Javascript Compiler gibt für irgendwas, keine Ahnung
Wahrscheinlich nicht, aber wenn du irgendwas lernen willst wo du überall was von hast dann ist es ehrlich gesagt Javascript
So viel wie Javascript vielleicht auch gebashed wird ist Javascript da das beste
Das nächste ist was sich auch auf jeden Fall lohnt und ihr wisst dass ich kein großer Fan bin
Aber ich muss tatsächlich sagen Java ist heute gerade im Enterprise Umfeld auch nicht wegzudenken
Java, dann hast du gerade was so Science Geschichten, AI Sachen angeht und halt so eher so die Zoomer Generation
Das ist dann so Richtung Python und nebenbei gibt es natürlich auch noch so Sachen wie Go und C-Sharp mit den jeweiligen Web Frameworks
Ich persönlich verwende ja C-Sharp am liebsten mit ASP.NET Core und man muss sagen Microsoft hat wirklich die letzten Jahre richtig krass das Ruder rumgerissen
Wohingegen Anfang des Jahrtausends, also so 2002, 2003 rum, als es so richtig losging mit.NET
Das war ja eine Windows, ich weiß es gab Mono, aber das war ja eigentlich zum größten Teil ein Windows Only Ding
Auch im Hinblick auf WPF und Zeug was Microsoft so gebastelt hat
Woran man übrigens auch sieht, dass Microsoft es damals schon nicht richtig hinbekommen hat
Weiß ich ob jemand die Zeit mitgekriegt hat, wo Microsoft bei Office und diesem ganzen Shit ihre Ribbon Bars eingeführt hat
Es gibt bis heute keine offizielle Ribbon Library für WPF
Sag ich jetzt einfach mal, auch wenn ich die letzten 10 Jahre nicht mehr verfolgt habe, wo soll die auf einmal herkommen
Und mit C-Sharp hast du auch was super universelles
Du kannst Web Anwendungen bauen, mit einem der besten Web, also ASP.NET Core wohlgemerkt, nicht das alte ASP.NET
Du hast eines der besten Web Frameworks, du kannst theoretisch sogar Frontend Sachen mit Blazer bauen, wobei ich das Paints Champ, ist nicht so mein Fall
Du kannst High Performance Sachen, du kannst mit C-Sharp.NET auch mehr oder weniger alles bauen heutzutage
Theoretisch auch Mobile Apps, wobei ich das auch eklig finde
Ja, lohnt sich aber auch auf jeden Fall
Wir sollen letztes Jahr in der Hochschule eine Webpage E-Git Knockout GS, da kann ich mich auch noch dran erinnern
Das ist halt schon uralt
Ja, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass Ruby on Rails angenehm und schön zu benutzen ist, Cobol nicht
Das stimmt, was Automatisierung angeht, ist Ruby tatsächlich relativ beliebt
Also meine ganzen Git Hooks auf der Arbeit sind auch noch alle in Ruby programmiert, wobei die demnächst halt wegfliegen, wenn wir komplett auf GitHub umziehen
Da gibt es ja keine klassischen Git Hooks mehr
Ansonsten haben wir eigentlich relativ wenig in Ruby noch
Ich habe vor mir wegen Exchange gedünstet
Da kenne ich mich echt nicht mit aus
Weder mit Exchange noch mit irgendwelchen Mail Geschichten, keine Ahnung
Ja, das will ich mir auch schon lange mal angucken
React Native ist auch wieder so ein schönes Beispiel für wie weit man mit JavaScript heutzutage kommt
Welche App willst du heute bauen? Nachdem ich keinen Plan habe von Svelte werde ich es mal bei einer To-Do App belassen
Aber zumindest so weit zum Deployen, dass ihr die auch nachher ausprobieren könnt
Meinung zu PHP?
Naja, mit dem passenden Framework sowas wie Laravel oder so ist das doch 2021 ganz nice
Wisst ihr was der riesen Vorteil von PHP ist?
Der unschlagbare nach wie vor Vorteil von PHP
Mal gucken ob einer drauf kommt
SQL mit drin? Ne, meine ich nicht
Was ich meine, was der unschlagbare Vorteil von PHP ist, es läuft überall
Der billigste China-Chinesen-Web-Hoster für 5 Cent im Monat hat PHP
Versuch mal Hosting zu bekommen, im normalen Web-Hosting inbegriffen, für Ruby, Java,.NET, Go, was kannst du vergessen
Da brauchst du schon irgendwelche Application-Geschichten von Containern, die du laufen lassen kannst
Oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen, die dafür explizit gedacht sind
Aber zu irgendeinem Billig-Hoster zu gehen und eine dynamische Webseite zu machen, das geht im Prinzip nur in PHP
Hat PHP mittlerweile vernünftiges Everhandling? Keine Ahnung, ich mach kaum PHP
Ich hoffe, dass Maui da großartig was dran ändert
Weil Maui ist doch im Prinzip auch nur Xamarin reskinned
Man kann natürlich auch Ausrufezeichen-Hetzner im Chat machen, das ist natürlich nur Big-Brain-Move
Das heißt, wenn ihr eure Sachen nicht bei irgendeinem billigen Web-Hoster laufen lassen wollt
Sondern ein bisschen höhere Ansprüche habt, dann könnt ihr euch jetzt meinen 20 Euro Startgutschein sichern
Und schon fast 3 Monate lang, huge host, 2 Leute, dankeschön
Schon 2-3 Monate lang einen Triple-Core-Server laufen lassen
Wofür hast du Git-Hooks? Um Server-Automatisierungszeug auf so einen Zwischenhop-Server zu schieben
Um Sündagschecks zu machen, automatisch, ob nicht irgendwie einer Shit eingecheckt hat ins Shit
Um Tests automatisch laufen zu lassen
Und, lass mal überlegen, das macht 3 großartige Sachen, aber auf die 3. komm ich jetzt grad gar nicht
Wanger-Tropfen für mir 95, danke für den Sub
Hm, ich hab's vergessen gerade, was ist noch, das macht 3 Sachen der Git-Hook
Tests, Sündagscheck, ach ja, Jammel-Sündagscheck, nochmal extra, weil wie wir alle wissen
Nur weil die Logik in Ordnung ist, heißt es noch lange nicht, dass Jammel-Sündagsfehler frei ist
Jammel
Also wenn einer beispielsweise Server-Automatisierungszeug eincheckt oder so, dann ist es ja schön zu gucken, ob was was ich, Ansible, Puppet, Chef, was auch immer, von der Logik her passt
Lässt mal ein Sündagscheck drüber laufen
Aber ob die Jammel-Config stimmt, mit den Einrückungen, das teste das ja gar nicht, deswegen hab ich noch ein Jammel-Sündagscheck drin
Wie gesagt, wir bauen das weiter von gestern, ich zeig euch gleich wo wir stehen geblieben sind
Ja, Go ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll zu lernen, ich mein man braucht Go nicht wirklich um Kubernetes und sonst so Sachen verwenden zu können
Aber im Cloud-Umfeld, wie sagt man so schön, im Cloud-Native-Umfeld oder generell im Cloud-Umfeld ist Go tatsächlich gerade bei Tools und halt auch bei so Sachen wie von Kubernetes bis Terra, bei Terraform ist glaub ich auch ein Go, ne?
Und Kram halt sehr verbreitet
Und es ist auf jeden Fall nicht schlecht zu können
Ich muss halt sagen, Go hat für mich so ein paar Dinge, die mich nerven
Das ist wahrscheinlich Gewöhnungssache, aber ich finde Go auf der einen Seite zu ausschweifen, sodass du irgendwie fünf verschiedene Varianten hast, wie du Variablen anlegen kannst
Und auf der anderen Seite zu minimalistisch, zum Beispiel, dass du keine gescheiten Möglichkeiten hast, Arrays zu filtern, sondern Schleife in Schleife in Schleife machen musst
Und die Go-Mailing-Liste sagt dazu dann Just Use Loops
Wenn du bei Go fragst, hier Jungs, warum kann ich denn nicht einfach sagen Array Punkt Filter irgendwas, dann sagen die ja Just Use Loops
Forehead
Von Generics reden wir mal gar nicht, das ist ja mittlerweile demnächst irgendwann bis 2050 da mal drinne
Ansonsten hat Go viele Sachen, wo ich mir denke, das ist zu viel ist gut und viele Sachen, wo ich mir denke, das ist zu wenig
Go ist echt Weird-Champ an vielen Stellen
Doch, doch, da gibt's Schlammwas
Das ist ja quasi eines der Kerndinger in Go, dass du zum Beispiel sein kannst
Go und dann irgendeine anonyme Funktion hintendran oder sowas pappst
Das geht schon, aber die haben nichts eingebaut dafür
Die haben da nichts eingebaut
Die haben nur quasi typlose, irgendwelche typlosen Slices für Arrays unter der Haube und das funktioniert nicht
Das ist eh super weird, du kannst in Go auch nicht einfach Sachen adden und löschen aus einer Liste und sowas
Du musst dann sagen add-Liste gleich append-Liste dieses Element
Das ist echt richtig Weird-Champ
Auf der einen Seite hat Go richtig nice Syntax-Geschichten, auf der anderen Seite so super umständlichen Kram
Genauso wie der Check in Go
Go check if key in
Nee, hash in map, map heißt der Kram
How to check if a map contains a key in Go
Ich find das super, ich find, äh Moment
Ja, doch, ich find das super weird-champed, wie das gemacht ist
Warum, warum muss das so kompliziert sein, auch dieses okay und so hintendran
Das sieht jetzt zwar nicht so schlimm aus, aber da kommt doch kein Mensch drauf, wenn er es nicht von Anfang an weiß, dass es so geht
Und warum gibt es nicht einfach ein dict.contains, wo dann true oder false rauskommt
Warum muss ich sowas da machen
Das mag zwar alles super, wie sagt man, ähm
Den, den, den Go, dem Go Geist irgendwie entsprechen, ja, aber ich find's nicht, nicht so wahnsinnig toll
Brings, Leute, ich muss mal hier, was ist mit meinem Logitech, mit meiner Tastatur los
Ich würde gerne meine Tastatur mit der ordentlichen Farbe haben und nicht so komisch blinkend
Fast wie als hätte ich Battlefield gestartet, da blinken die Tastatur auch immer wie verrückt
Hallo, Tastatur, please, ah jetzt, okay
Ja, also das finde ich in Go nicht so, nicht so wahnsinnig toll
So, ich glaube, ich habe den Chat gleich durch
Nee, das checkt einfach nur, ob es drin ist
Du müsstest dann sagen, dict.foo gleich eins oder sowas
So, also, gehen wir mal hier rüber
Also, ich zeige euch mal, wo wir gestern stehen geblieben sind
Und dann zeige ich euch mal, wie wir das Deployment machen auf den Server
Ich habe dann nämlich schon mal ein bisschen was vorbereitet, weil wir wissen ja
Die Zoomer-Aufmerksamkeit Spanne ist nicht sonderlich hoch und ich muss die Sachen nicht 50 mal zeigen
Also, wo wir gestern stehen geblieben sind, ist hier Folgendes
Ich habe zum ersten Mal was mit Svelte gemacht
Und wir haben die Poggers-App programmiert
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das ging, Run?
Run? Flutter? Run? Nein
NPM run dev open
Ah ja, wir haben was absolut ungestyltes, hässliches programmiert
Wir haben Two-Way-Data-Binding getestet in Svelte
Wir haben Komponenten angelegt, wir haben Animationen getestet
Das hier ist übrigens eine Animation
Also, dass das hier so schön ein- und ausfaded, ist JavaScript-Animation, die in Svelte eingebaut ist
Das ist nicht irgendwie CSS oder HTML oder sowas Keyframe-Animationen
Das sind eingebaute JavaScript-Logik für Animationen eigentlich relativ nice
Wir haben geguckt, wie das ist mit Data-Binding und mit
Ich mache das gerade mal kurz auf
Und mit Komponenten anlegen
Das war's
Mehr haben wir gestern nicht gemacht
Das hier ist quasi meine
Ich kriege das Svelte-Tutorial durch und probiere Dinge aus
Das haben wir gestern im Stream gemacht
So, und heute probieren wir mal eine simple To-Do-App zu basteln
Und die dann zu hosten in Hetzer Cloud, dass ihr die aufmachen könnt
Die wird nichts bringen
Also, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ihr sagen könnt, jawoll, ich schmeiß jetzt Wunderlist oder was es alles gibt über einen Haufen
Benutzt dann die super Poggers To-Do-App
Die wird sich für nichts großartig eignen, außer dreimal Sachen rumzuklicken und festzustellen, ah, es funktioniert
Stimmt, was Go angeht, haben wir wirklich ein paar ziemlich clevere Leute im Discord
Habe ich auch schon im Programmier-Channel gesehen
Voll fett, Svelte plus Tailwind, nee, Tailwind will ich, wobei Tailwind könnten wir auch noch mal gucken, wie man das einbindet, ja
Gucken wir mal, aber wir machen jetzt erstmal eine neue App
Ich zeig euch mal, ich habe eine Sache schon vorbereitet
Und zwar, ähm, machen wir das hier mal kurz wieder zu
Ich hab hier schon einen Ordner angelegt, Kicks To-Do
Nee, es heißt nicht To-Do-Champ, es bleibt aber mal Kicks To-Do
Und ich hab da schon ein Enzyme Playbook angelegt, um den Server automatisch konfigurieren zu lassen
Bei Hetzner, weil das haben wir schon 30 Milliarden Mal gemacht
Das muss ich nicht jedes Mal neu machen, ich zeig euch aber mal kurz, was das macht
Wir legen jetzt einfach eine Hello World App an und die schieben wir zu Hetzner in die Cloud
Und dann könnt ihr unter To-Do, wartet mal, irgendwie
Zack, warum ist das hier?
Irgendwie ist der Sound auf der einen Seite gerade anders als auf der anderen
Oder mein Ohr ist gerade abgekratzt
Ihr könnt dann unter, jetzt passt mal auf was für eine super nice Domain wir haben
To-Do.hackw.services
Könnt ihr dann gleich die App aufrufen
Und ihr seht schon, wir haben ein gültiges Let's Encrypt Zertifikat
Und das wird alles für uns gehandelt
Aber noch ist ja nichts deployed, deswegen ist nichts da
Wir können euch gleich über das ganze Cloud-Technik, Server-Technik machen, wir legen mal so eine billige Hello World App an und deployen die dann
Und dann gucken wir, ob es geht, und wenn es geht, zeige ich euch, wie es funktioniert
Also, wie ging das noch mal? Neue App erstellen
hackw.services, das haben wir unseren richtigen 5Hat Mods zu verdanken
Eine Runde Mod-Check in den Chat
So, wie ging das noch mal?
npx, nee, init
ja
init-todo, genau
So, die super Poggers-App machen wir weg unten
Name not resolved, warum?
Es sollten 503 geben, weil es keinen Service hinter dem Load Balancer gibt
So, also legen wir mal eine to-do-App an, ach nee, nicht to-do, nicht to-do, geh weg
Nicht einfach to-do, oder? Doch, doch, komm
Kein to-do hätte ich da unten können
Also, Skeleton Project, kein TypeScript, kein Linting, kein Pretty, aber braucht dann sowas
King Dennis vom Palace, excellent Prime Subscription, Dankeschön
So, und jetzt, das habe ich mir im Vorfeld schon angeguckt
Weil ich das nicht, weil ich das überhaupt nicht gecheckt habe, wie ich eine SvelteKit App deployen kann
Das ist jetzt die einfachste SvelteKit App, die es gibt
Ein leeres, quasi im Prinzip ein leeres Hello World Template
Das kann man auch mal starten, mpm, was war das, run?
Ja, so, da steht nichts anderes wie welcome to SvelteKit da
Ich kann zu Versal deployen, ja, aber wir deployen zu Hetzner Cloud, weil
Ausrufezeichen Hetzner könnt ihr euch an 20 Euro Startgutschein sichern
Nur noch bis Ende 31.12.2021 und auch nur für Neukunden
Damit könnt ihr beispielsweise einen Triple Core Server
Damit könnt ihr beispielsweise einen Triple Core Server fast 3 Monate laufen lassen, guck mal
Triple Core Server kostet aktuell 8,21 Euro im Monat oder 13...
Ne, 1,3 Cent die Stunde, sehe ich das richtig?
Quickmaps
Und das wird übrigens stündlich abgerechnet, das heißt
Wenn ihr jetzt zum Beispiel sagt, hey, ich brauche mal was super Fettes
Sowas hier, 32 Core, 128 GB
Dann könnt ihr euch das mieten, für zwei Stunden verwenden
Und dann bezahlt ihr bloß einen Euro
Hat Hetzner auch sowas wie AWS Lambda oder Serverless?
Nein, das gibt es noch nicht, ich weiß auch nicht, ob die sowas geplant haben
Aber ich vermute mal, dass sie schon am Überlegen sind, in welche Richtung sie noch so ihre Fühler ausstrecken können
Also mir persönlich wäre es am liebsten, bevor die sowas machen
Es gibt 3 Sachen, die ich mir noch wünschen würde
Keine Ahnung, nur weil ich jetzt hier Sponsoringgeschichte mache, habe ich da keinen weiteren Einblick drin
Aber es gibt 3 Sachen, die ich mir wünschen würde, so nächster Zeit, was bei Hetzner Cloud noch kommen würde
Das erste sind Managed Datenbanken
Mir persönlich reicht eine Postgres
Die werden bestimmt nichts eigenes machen, wie Microsoft, wozu auch
Managed Datenbanken fände ich schon mal ziemlich nice, wenn es das gäbe
Das nächste ist, dass es, einfach nur weil das gerade sehr angesagt ist, wenn die irgendeine Managed Kubernetes Geschichte hätten
Und das dritte wäre tatsächlich sowas in der Richtung
Irgendwas Serverless für Functions
Wobei die Managed Datenbanken mir persönlich am wichtigsten sind, vielleicht machen sie das ja auch wirklich
Wo ist Whoop Arife hin?
Doch, geht doch noch
Achso, du bist kein Zapp mehr, ha!
Lul
Kein Wunder, dass es nicht funktioniert
Ja, natürlich, du kannst das selbst hosten, aber die Frage, wenn du das selbst hosten kannst
Warum biete dann Amazon und Microsoft diese Sachen an, wenn es keiner haben will?
Was genau meinst du mit Managed Datenbanken?
Naja, dass ich zum Beispiel, ich bin jetzt hier im Frontend
Dass ich zum Beispiel sagen kann, anstatt Server, add database
Und dann wähle ich dann so ein paar grundsätzliche Parameter für die Datenbank aus
Und am Ende kriege ich meinen Connection String und alles ist gut
Finish
Ich muss mich nicht selbst um HA kümmern
Ich muss mich nicht selbst um Backups kümmern
Ich muss mich nicht selbst um irgendwelches Partitioning, Performance Geschichts oder sonst was kümmern
Das fände ich gut
Managed Datenbank, das fände ich gut
Und richtig advanced, so richtig premium wäre das
Hätten die noch die Möglichkeit, ein CraftQL Managed vor die Datenbank zu machen
Das wäre richtig Porgas, aber das wollte man nicht übertreiben
Ja, das musste leider selbst über die API basteln
Aktuell habe ich meine Domain halt über Hetzner laufen
Also die DNS über Hetzner laufen
So, also wo sind wir denn jetzt stehen geblieben?
Ihr wollt jetzt ja nicht die ganze Zeit nur Werbung machen
Genau, also wir haben eine Hello World Svelte App angelegt
Und die deployen wir jetzt mal
Und ich habe im Vorfeld schon ein bisschen geguckt, wie das funktioniert
Und zwar damit man Svelte Apps deployen kann
Muss man dem sagen, wohin sie deployen oder als was sie deployen werden sollen
Da muss ich jetzt ein bisschen ausholen, warum
Soweit ich das verstanden habe, ist nämlich ein Feature von SvelteKit
Das der Server-Side-Rendering macht
Also sprich, wenn diese Seite hier jetzt geöffnet wird
Dann passieren zwei Sachen
Ihr bekommt initial diese Seite einmal prerendert als HTML ausgeliefert vom Server
Gleichermaßen, wenn dort Klein-Sides-Sachen drin sind
Zum Beispiel, dass ich das On-The-Fly irgendwie updatet und subscribes zu irgendeinem Craft-QL oder sonst was
Die Klein-Sides-Sachen werden dann quasi auch gestartet, sobald ihr die Seite bekommen habt
Also die versuchen so ein bisschen das Beste aus beiden Welten miteinander zu verbinden
Dass es schnell aufgerufen wird
Machen die Server-Side-Rendering für das meiste was geht
Und dann wird das Ganze quasi übergeben an irgendwelche Klein-Side-Geschichten
Und dass es weiter wie so x-beliebiges Klein-Side-Single-Page-Application läuft
So, deswegen kann man bei SvelteKit auch nicht einfach sagen
Mache mir da statisches HTML und JavaScript raus und lege es in irgendeinem Web-Route-Folder
Und lasse es mit irgendeinem x-beliebigen Webserver ausliefern
Das geht nicht, so ohne weiteres
Weil sonst, doch das geht, aber da muss man auf Server-Side-Rendering verzichten
Was man wohl machen kann ist, weil ich gesehen habe
Die bieten hier verschiedene Sachen an, wie man das Ganze deployen kann
Da gibt es zum Beispiel auch einen Node-Adapter
Oder man kann die ganzen Sachen auf Cloudflare deployen, Netlify, Versal deployen
Oder als Node-Adapter für x-beliebige Linux-Systeme
Und was dann passiert ist, wenn ich das eintrage und das bilden lasse
Dann kommt ein Ordner raus, wo quasi eine komplette Node.js Anwendung drin liegt
Die ich dann auf meinem Server einfach starten kann
Das probieren wir jetzt aus und dafür habe ich das nämlich auch schon angepasst
Dass das so auf unsere Linux-Kiste deployed wird
Ich mache das jetzt einfach mal
Und dann gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert
Yes, wir trusten, immer trusten
Immer trust
Dazu müssen wir in die Svelte-Conf-Adapter-Node eintragen
Und hier unten anstatt Adapter das hier eintragen
Da, da
Output-Directory nennen wir auch mal www.root
Einfach weil ich mich daran gewöhnt habe, dass der Krempel so heißt
Das muss natürlich nicht so heißen
So, und wenn ich jetzt da hingehe und sage
NPM run a build ist es glaube ich
Dann habe ich vorher vergessen NPM install zu machen
Und ich muss noch machen NPM install den Node-Adapter
Das habe ich ganz vergessen
Alter, JavaScript-Dependency-Management, lul
So, und jetzt kann ich ein Bild machen
Und jetzt gibt es hier ein Ordner www.root
In dem, wenn ich da hingehe, eine Node.js-Anwendung liegt
Die ich einfach starten kann hier, äh, nicht nide
Node-Index.js
Und wenn ich jetzt in dem Fall auf localhost port 3000 gehe
Dann läuft die Seite da
Das verbindet jetzt das Beste aus beiden Welten
Wenn ich, wie gesagt, ich habe gestern erst damit angefangen das mir anzugucken
Das verbindet, so wie ich das verstanden habe, das Beste aus beiden Welten
Du hast Server-Site Rendering initial
Und bei jedem weiteren Refresh der Seite quasi kleinzeitig
Das heißt du kriegst die Seite schnell
Und du kannst kleinzeit, äh, Updates machen
Das ist schon eine coole Geschichte
Zumal das für Suchmaschinen auch viel besser ist
So eine Pre-Rendered Server-Site-Geschichte zu bekommen
Ja, was halt geil ist
Weil, ich glaube jeder, der mal größere, ähm
Single-Page-Applications verwendet hat
Oder zumindest, sagen wir so
An Web-Anwendungen zum größeren Teil kleinzeitig läuft, weiß das lädt halt eine Weile
Wenn ihr zum ersten Mal Spotify aufmacht
Hat das zumindest eine ganze Weile gedauert früher
Amazon-Musik hat auch eine Weile gedauert bis das geladen ist
Was sind denn noch so bekannte Kleinzeit-Applications
Wo viel Kleinzeit läuft, was fällt euch da ein
Discord, Discord
Ok, Discord stelle ich mir vor, stelle ich mir schwierig vor, äh, Pre- zu rendern
Google-Mail, ja
Gmail, Gmail ist ein super, ist ein super, super Beispiel für
Gmail dauert eine ganze Weile bis es aufgeht
Gmail könnte man wunderbar machen
Server-Site gerendert, initial ausliefern
Dann würde quasi, wenn du Gmail öffnest
Würde das quasi instant aufgehen
Aber das hätte trotzdem alle Funktionen
Also sprich, wir haben quasi mittlerweile dadurch das Beste aus beiden Welten
Früher haben wir nur Server-Site-Rendering gemacht
Du hast quasi Server-Site was gerendert, fertiges HTML ausgeliefert
Und es war ein bisschen JavaScript drin, um die Seite vielleicht ein bisschen dynamisch zu machen
Aber sonst nichts großartiges
Dann war es eine Zeit lang im Trend, dass man eigentlich auf dem Server gar nichts mehr gerendert hat
Sondern initial einfach 8 MB JavaScript ausgeliefert hat
Und dass sich dann alles kleinzeitig gestartet hat
Und über irgendwelche APIs sich die Daten geholt hat und dann irgendwas angezeigt
War halt lahm
Und jetzt hat man quasi beides, man kann die Seite prerendert auf dem Server
Und dann so handoff machen zum Client
Eigentlich von der Technik her richtig nice
Und deswegen muss ich das jetzt bauen, da fällt eine Node-Anwendung raus
Wenn ich die Node-Anwendung starte, habe ich halt hier prerendert
Mein Welcome to Swagkit
Und gleichermaßen halt auch, wenn ich dynamische Sachen kleinzeitig machen würde
Könnte ich ab der Stelle weiter machen
Du hast halt quasi kleinzeit und schnell gerendert in einem
So, und jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, wie wir das ganze deployen können
Wir schauen mal, ob das jetzt einfach funktioniert
In der Regel funktioniert ja nie was einfach
Aber wie gesagt, ich habe das im Vorfeld schon ausprobiert
Ich hoffe mal, das funktioniert jetzt einfach
Und wenn das...
Oh, sorry
Ich bin gerade gegen das Mikro vorgekommen
Und wenn das funktioniert
Dann zeige ich euch, wie ich es gemacht habe
Node mit Express, ich habe keine Ahnung, was die unter einer Haube verwenden
Können wir mal gucken
Wahrscheinlich
Was benutzen die denn?
Die rappen irgendwelche Dinger
Ah, jetzt Simple Characters, alles klar
Jaja, okay
Mhm, mhm
Alles klar, Obvious, Obvious
Mhm
Okay, alles klar
Gut
Ich gucke mir das nicht weiter an
Das bleibt einfach so
Ich glaube, dass es irgendwie
Nicht auf Lesbarkeit ausgelegt
So würde ich es auch machen, genau
Ich glaube, dass es nicht auf Lesbarkeit ausgelegt
Sondern irgendwie halt ein
Ein Fein, wo alles hintereinander geschmissen wurde
Automatisch generiert
Ich denke nicht, dass das eine von Hand erstellt hat
Genau, ich denke auch, dass das
Minifight ist
Nicht extra Opfuß geltet, aber Minifight ist
Und zusätzlich noch
Wobei, da hätten wir keine Kommentare drin, wenn es Minifight ist
Haben wir Kommentare drin?
Ja
Ach, keine Ahnung
Sollen sie machen, ist mir egal
Ich deploy den Camp jetzt erstmal
Ansible
So, Playbook
So
Also
Wir können mal hoffen, dass das funktioniert
Das haben wir das letzte Mal schon gemacht
Das ist vom letzten Stream, wo wir CAC WSS Service deployt haben
Ihr erinnert euch noch vielleicht
Wir benutzen das Hetzner Cloud
CLI Tool, um neue Server anzulegen
Also
Hetzner Cloud Server Create
Location
Nürnberg
Label
To Do
Das Label ist, dass ich weiß, welche Server zu welcher Anwendung gehören
Weil es könnte ja sein, dass ihr 5 Anwendungen laufen habt
Oder 50
Und ihr müsst auf einen Blick mal kurz filtern
Welche Anwendungen gehören da dazu
Und da ist das mit Label ganz praktisch
Wir benutzen heute mal Debian 11
Einfach, weil es ein bisschen neuere Node Versionen gibt
Einfach, weil sie ein bisschen neuere Node Versionen drauf haben
Als Ubuntu 20.04
Wir nehmen eine Triple Core Kiste
Die gleiche
Label ist Key Value
Ja, aber du kannst das Value weglassen
Dann ist das einfach wie so ein Tag
Diese Kiste könnt ihr übrigens auch
Ungefähr für 3 Monate betreiben
Wenn ihr euch mal einen 20€ Startgutschein sichert
Nur noch bis 31.12
Huge Sellout Modus
Ausrufzeichen, Hetzner im Chat
Muss man noch in Bomber rein schieben jetzt
So, Name des Servers ist KicksToDo
Stonks
SSH Key League
Ah mein Name, oh je
Also
So heißt der Server da nachher
Wir bleiben bei einem, das reicht
SSH Key
Das ist das, was man zum Einloggen verwendet
Test der Test, ja
Ich hab mir extra hier für einen angelegt
Da weiß man doch Bescheid
Test der Test SSH Key
Ähm
Dann nehme ich die IP
Vom Server nachdem der angelegt wurde
Und warte 20 Sekunden
Und dann lasse ich mein Ansible Playbook darauf los
Wir gucken jetzt einfach mal ob es funktioniert
Bäm
Ok, Server ist angelegt
Können wir auch hier mal nachgucken
Guckt da, KicksToDo
Alles da
Die IP vom Server
Wenn einen D DOSen will
Tut euch keinen Zwang an
So, jetzt läuft das Ansible Zeug
Und wenn es jetzt funktioniert
Sollte da drauf gleich
Meine Hello World, oh nee
Waluigi Mario Kart Sounds
Wäw, wäw, wäw, wäw
Ja, kann ich euch vorstellen
Ähm
Hab ich nie richtig ausprobiert
Ich hab mal den offiziellen Dogger Container gestartet
Und mir das ein bisschen angeguckt
Ich hab damit noch nie was gemacht, großartig
Container Native
Excellent, ok
Angeblich hat alles funktioniert Leute
Können wir mal gucken
Können wir mal gucken ob
Im Load Balancer
Ob das Service ready wird
Unhealthy
Mal gucken ob es schon funktioniert
Tudu.kw.services
So
Da hat irgendwas halt funktioniert
Gut
Ah, jetzt gehts
Das hat einfach ein bisschen gebraucht
Ok
Hey
Also wenn ihr auf
Tudu.kw.services geht
Solltet ihr jetzt Welcome to SwellKit bekommen
Gut
So wie funktioniert das ganze, ich zeig euch das Deployment mal
Bevor wir uns dann an die Tudu App
Wagen
Wie funktioniert das Deployment
Das besteht aus zwei Schritten
Also, erstmal hab ich euch hier gratuliert
Leg ich mal den Server an über das
Hetzer CLI Tool
Und danach, um den Server zu konfigurieren, lass ich mein
Ensemble Playbook laufen
Das
Der Webservice da drauf funktioniert, liegt aber
Daran, dass ich noch einen Hetzer Load Balancer davor hab
Das Feature ist noch nicht so alt
Das gibt's glaube ich erst so
Seit zwei, drei Monaten
Früher hat es hier nur die Möglichkeit Server anzulegen
Platten anzulegen
Und die Geschichte
Mit Load Balancer und Firewall Regeln
Ist relativ neu
So und was ich hier gemacht hab ist
Ich hab ne Load Balancer angelegt
Der automatisch
Zertifikate
Also sich Zertifikate abruft
Für die Domain
Und
Der alle Services
Achso
Als Load Balanced wird von
TPS auf Port 3000
Ne, das ist keine Floating IP
Als heißt, wenn irgendjemand
Scheiße damit macht
Muss ich die Load Balancer wegschmeißen
Ähm
Und als Target nimmt er alle Server
Die als Tag To Do dran stehen haben
Deswegen muss ich eben den Server anlegen
Mit Label To Do
Also sprich, wenn ich jetzt noch einen zweiten Server
Anlege
Mit dem gleichen Label
Dann ist der Load Balancer davor
Und macht es auf beide Server
Das ist natürlich äußerst praktisch
So und wenn der Server
Aufgebaut ist
Also wenn der Server angelegt ist
Dann wartet er 20 Sekunden
Und dann lässt er das Ansible Playbook laufen
So was macht das Ansible Playbook
Das zeige ich euch jetzt auch nochmal schnell
Das ist für Leute, die hier schon öfters mal reingeguckt haben
Absolut nichts neues, weil
Das ist ein Playbook zum größten Teil
Was wir für fast alle
Ähm
Ubuntu oder Debian Server
Verwendet haben bisher
Wir haben das sogar mal irgendwann zusammen
Im Stream erstellt
Also
Was das macht ist folgendes
Als erstes werden erst mal Pakete geupdatet
Und das Betriebssystem aktualisiert
Dann wird Telnet
Git, Vim, Hardtop, Enno,
Tmux, T-Stats, NetTools und
Node.js installiert
Node.js habe ich jetzt hier hinzugefügt
Weil letztendlich wollen wir Node.js Anwendungen laufen lassen
Warum Telnet
Weil Telnet manchmal ganz praktisch ist neben
Sachen wie Netcat um einfach zu checken ob
Verbindungen funktionieren
Also wenn man einfach nur checken will ob was funktioniert
Das ist zum Beispiel relativ praktisch zu machen
Telnet google.de port 80
Und dann einfach zu sagen
Git
Das ist zum ausprobieren
Ganz praktisch
Git ist klar Versionsdings Editor
Prozess Übersicht
Endload ist für Netzwerkauslastung
Das
Playbook liegt in meinem GitHub allerdings
Nicht für die aktuelle
Geschichte aber das prinzipielle
Playbook liegt hier
Unter
Cacv as a service
Das habe ich genommen und nur ein bisschen angepasst
Für die neue
Geschichte jetzt
Könnte mich jedes mal immer noch über
Cacv as a service kaputtlachen
So
Dann eine Sache die man normalerweise nicht
Braucht die ich aber brauche
Wenn ich mich einlogge zeigt er nicht meine
IP an
Dann Restart
Der SSH um die Sachen zu aktivieren
Dann legt er einen extra User an
Unter dem wir später unsere
Anwendung laufen lassen
Dann legt er ein Systemd Unit File
An für Kegs To Do
Oder für unsere To Do Anwendung
In diesem Systemd
File steht dann zum Beispiel drinne
Zum Dinger wie das wir
Das unter Home App
Der User den wir oben angelegt haben
Starten wollen mit
Node.js
Und die Datei ausführen wollen
Das ist das was wir eben angelegt haben hier guck da
www root
index.js
Dass ich das immer automatisch neu startet
Service
Syslog Identifier habe ich vergessen zu überschreiben
Den sollten wir Kegs To Do nennen
Er lässt es als User
App laufen
Und das da unten kann ich rausschmeißen
Weil das ist ASP.NET spezifisches
Das brauchen wir nicht
So
Danach schaltet er das ein und startet den Service
Und die nächsten Tasks sind
Eigentlich nur
Achso vielleicht soll ich noch eins sagen
Das da oben ist Run Once
Also wenn ich das jetzt nochmal ausführen sollte
Gegen den gleichen Server
Dann macht er das nicht alles nochmal
So
Danach
Das ist um die Sachen ein bisschen abzukürzen
Geht er bei mir lokal
In den Ordner wo die To Do App drin liegt
Macht einen NPM Build
Und danach deploit das
Über SCP
Auf den Server und startet den Service neu
Das heißt jedes Mal
Wenn ich jetzt hier was dran geändert habe
Sage ich einfach
Ähm
Ja gut
Jetzt kann ich den Server aufbauen
Geschiss drum herum weg machen
Sage ich einfach Ansible Playbook
Auf dieser IP
Bumsch
So man sieht es geht schon viel schneller
Das mit dem Run Once
Hat glaube ich nicht funktioniert weil ich gerade was geändert habe
So fertig
Das heißt jedes Mal wenn ich
Ok das mit dem Run Once funktioniert doch nicht
Ja gut
Warum funktioniert das mit dem Run Once nicht
Ich dachte man macht das so
Zumindest wenn ich jetzt lokal was dran ändere
An der Anwendung will die neu deployen
Zum Beispiel gehen wir jetzt mal her und sagen
Habe ich die noch auf hier innen
Ja also zum Beispiel ich gehe jetzt hier
Auf die Startseite
Und da steht das nicht
Welcome to Svelte Kids sondern
Keine Ahnung einfach nur
Aja ja
Pipe Head
Trage ich das da ein
Tue mal ein Playbook neu aus
Ah das ist mit Run Once gemeint
Verstehe
Ist er?
Das wusste ich gar nicht
So
Build, Copy, App
Play, Recap
So und wenn ich jetzt auf
To Do Punkt
Keqwe Punkt Services gehe
Dann sehen wir
Aja ja Fallfahrt
Also so schnell kann es gehen
Mit neuer App Version deployt
Also natürlich
Äußerst praktisch
Hat jemand eine Ahnung wie ich das bei Ansible mache
Dass ich das hier skippen kann
Muss ich dann Tags für verwenden oder so
Dass ich dem sagen kann ich möchte nur
Den Job ausführen
Der Build und Deploy heißt
Ansible
Execute Job
Ne
Am einfachsten mit Tags
Keine Ahnung
Ich lasse es jetzt einfach so laufen
Weil eigentlich geht es ja darum dass wir irgendeine Svelte To Do App bauen
So also ihr seht
Das ist tatsächlich ziemlich einfach
Wenn man sich mal so nen
Es muss ja nicht zwangsläufig ein Ansible Skript sein
Das ist so ziemlich die simpelste Variante davon
Normalerweise würde man
Das auch anders machen
Du hättest noch nen Inventory File
Und würdest nicht Hardcoded irgendwelche IPs
Reinschreiben oder sowas in der Richtung
Aber zum demonstrieren ist das hier eigentlich
Die simpelste Variante die man machen kann
Daran sieht man schonmal warum
Server Automatisierung
Auch für so einfache Sachen
Eine gute Idee ist
Weil auch wenn das jetzt wirklich simpel ist
Und innerhalb von
Zehn Minuten von Hand gemacht ist
Ähm
Es gibt hier drin
Mindestens
Ich schätze mal 20 Stellen
Wo ich mich verschreiben könnte
Sei es hier beispielsweise diese Dinger
Die Namen von der App
Sei es irgendwelche Verzeichnisse hier unten drunter
Ich vergesse irgendwelche Packages
Zu installieren
Ich vergesse diese IP Geschichten
Zumal ich vergesse SSH9 zu starten
Ich leg den falschen User an
Was auch immer
Um so Sachen Server Automatisierung zu machen
Und gerade mit sowas
Und wenn man das dann in so ein kleines Skript packt
Habt ihr gesehen wie einfach und schnell das geht
Dass ein Server erstellt wird
Der instant im Loadbalancing drinne ist
Und eine Webanwendung surft
Reicht nicht NPM Run Build
Äh, was mach ich denn hier?
Mache ich doch NPM Run Build
Ich führe das hier aus
Dann geht er in dieses Verzeichnis
Und sagt NPM
NPM Run Build
Oder wie oder was
Gut, jetzt aber jetzt
Witfen wir mal unserer To Do App
Jetzt widmen wir mal uns unserer To Do App
Und jetzt, ich hoffe es ist gestern
Was hängen geblieben
Vor dem Swell Tutorial was ich gemacht hab
Fun Fact, du kannst auch deine lokale CLI
Mit da reinpacken
Äh
Du meinst das hier?
Achso, jaja
Ich weiß, ich weiß
Ich weiß, du kannst sogar die
Hetzner CLI
Äh, äh
Endsible Integration
Theoretisch verwenden
Gibt eine
Aber ich finde das so praktischer
Da kannst du das
Weiß nicht
Selig Geschmack, Sarah
So, also jetzt gucken wir uns mal
Die
Äh, Swell Geschichte an
Was ich mir davon gemerkt hab, gucken wir mal
Wir müssen auf jeden Fall erstmal
Den lokalen Server starten
Dass ich sehe wenn was passiert
Zack
Okay
Wir wollen eine To Do App machen
Das Ding heißt
Kicks To Do
Und das ist auch cool, dass die automatisch
Äh, so
Hot Reload dabei haben
So
Super hübsche Seite schonmal
Achja, by the way, jetzt mal wieder
Guck mal, guck mal wie schnell sich
Das deployen könnte
Playbook, bam
Normalerweise würde ich das jetzt überspringen
Weil ich zu dumm bin, Text einzubauen
Ratter das jetzt noch durch
Dumm da dumm da dumm da dumm
So ab jetzt muss man die Zeit stoppen
Also in Wirklichkeit würde das 2 Sekunden
Dauern und zack, Kicks To Do
Instant Deployed
So
Wie mach ich das mit Text
Würdest du es mal kurz angucken
Endsible
Skip
Ask
Conditionals
When
Kann ich den When
Direkt hier oben
rein machen
Wahrscheinlich nicht
Achja
Text
Ok, da probieren wir das
Kann man Text oben übergeordnet machen
Text, sowas Text
Basic
Und dann hier unten
Text
Deploy
Geht das
Endsible, Run, Text
Und jetzt
Ok
Minus Minus
Text, geht das so?
Hey
Easy
Guck mal
Wie schnell das jetzt geht, das ist doch nice
Oh jetzt habe ich das zu gemacht
Ich kack noob
Richtig pfeilfert
So machen wir die To Do App nochmal auf
Open
Hack
Das ist richtig, ich finde das jedes Mal reich
So, was weiß ich
Ich bin jetzt der Meinung, das Ding sollte nicht Kicks To Do H2
H1, sondern Kicks To Do H2 sein
So, gespeichert
Endsible, Deploy
4, 5, 6
So, das hat 6 Sekunden
gedauert
Neue Version zu deploy, also viel schneller
Viel schneller bist du auch mit einem super krassen
internationalisierten Kubernetes Cluster nicht
Nur mit dem Unterschied
Da lässt es sich natürlich einfacher
horizontal, diagonal, vertikal
auf und ab und runter skalieren
als mit so einer Geschichte wie ich sie
gebaut habe
Er hat alles seine Vor- und Nachteile
Aber das ist schon ziemlich zackig
und schnell
Callback, Whiteless, Profile, Tester
Ich habe noch nicht mal eine Endsible
Ich habe nur eine Server-Yaml
Kann ich das auch reinschreiben?
6 Sekunden, die bleiben
ohne Tests
Ja gut
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich dafür Tests brauche
Okay
Kicks To Do, also Zeit mal her
Ich muss mal in mich gehen
Ich habe viel über das Welt gelernt
Erstmal braucht man einen Script Tag
In dem Script Tag kann man
so Sachen machen wie
To Do's
Mal gucken ob ich das noch
gecheckt habe
Okay, ja
Okay, das ist schon mal richtig
Okay, To Do's
So, also
Wie könnte man so eine To Do App bauen?
Also, ein To Do braucht
Was ist das für eine hässliche Formatierung, Alter
Ein To Do braucht eine ID, oder?
Eine ID
Ein Text
Null
Und ein
So irgendwie dann
Falls
Oder Status
Dann wie auch immer
Okay, jetzt Big Brain Time
Wie macht man nochmal eine Schleife
ins Welt?
Each
Nee
Aha
Each
Ah guck mal, mir kriegen sie sogar angezeigt
unten wie es funktioniert
Oh
Autocomplete
Pokchamp
Ähm
Autocomplete
Each To Do's
As To Do, so?
Ich hab gestern zum ersten Mal was ins
Welt gemacht, mal gucken ob, nein
ID?
Ja, okay, funktioniert, funktioniert prinzipiell
Ähm, kann ich das, kann ich das jetzt
undi
undestructen oder sowas?
Wie heißt das nochmal genau?
Nee
Nee, so?
Oh, wie ging das?
Nee, das geht an der Stelle
glaube ich nicht, oder?
Hinter S
irgendwie
Ja
Jason Stringify, das wäre, das
würde, das würde auf jeden Fall funktionieren
man konnte das doch irgendwie so
so destructen lassen oder so
Sekunde
Each
Gucken wir uns nochmal an
Äh
SID Text
Ah
So?
Ja, aber wenn ich die
Dinger nicht weiß, ich kann
jetzt nicht einfach so hier sagen, oder?
Nee
Oh, das ist, das ist jetzt
Brocken
Was macht das jetzt überhaupt?
Jetzt habe ich, jetzt habe ich es zerstört, glaube ich
Ja, jetzt ist, jetzt ist kaputt
Okay, keine Ahnung
Wir, wir bleiben, wir belassen uns mal
wir belassen uns mal dabei
Hallo?
Okay, gut
Also, das funktioniert
Kannst du nicht, das da, das da?
Weiß ich nicht, ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht
das müsste so schon funktionieren
Nee
Keine Ahnung
Ist auch egal
So, funktioniert es auf jeden Fall
Wir können ja dann Sachen anzeigen lassen, die wir anzeigen lassen wollen
So, okay
So, das ist unsere To-Do-Liste
Das ist unsere To-Do-Liste
So, okay
So, das ist unsere To-Do-Liste
Wie, wie, okay
Okay, bevor wir das stylen, muss erstmal
die Funktion irgendwie drinne sein
Each To-Do ist erst, das hatte ich gerade schon ausprobiert
Das hat auch nicht funktioniert, ist auch wurscht
Ist auch egal, ich meine, ich kann mich auch dran erinnern
Die hatten sowas hier irgendwie als Beispiel
drinne
Aber ich finde es jetzt nicht mehr
Ich finde es nicht mehr
Ist auch egal
Ist jetzt nicht unser Problem
So, jetzt brauchen wir den Button
Button
Sowas wie
Add
Oh, das ist die, das wird die schönste To-Do-App
auf diesem Planeten
Ich sehe es schon, ich sehe es schon, komm
Wir können, nein Leute, wir nehmen
Material Design Icons
Wie kriege ich Material Design Icons
in meine Svelte-App
Gibt es da schon irgendwas fertiges für?
Svelte Material UI
Ne, das meine ich nicht
Svelte Material Icons
Sowas in der Richtung
Ich meine, ich kann es installieren, das ist kein Ding
Ja
Okay, da braucht man keinen extra
Campel für
Wir können aber auch
Wisst ihr was noch viel besser ist
Die Tailwind-Leute haben doch
sowas extra, das Hero-Icons
Die kannst du nämlich einfach Copy-Pasten
Das ist noch, das ist noch simpler zu benutzen
Wir brauchen jetzt Add
Add plus Circle
Copyed
Da ist er hier, bam
Massive
Add, Add Circle
Ich glaube, da müssen wir aber eine Diff
draus machen, sonst funktioniert das nicht
Eats
Okay
Glass
Okay, Style
Puffspixel, so wunderbar
Massive, Massive Add-Button
Huge
Ich sag euch, das wird
Super, super
Eine Augenweide, eine wahre
Augenweide, diese To-Do-App
Break
HTML von 1995
Also wir haben
unseren Add-Knopf
Wie bindet man da jetzt noch mal OnClick
Wie ging das jetzt
On, ne
Click
So
OnClick
Genau
Da brauchen wir jetzt eine Funktion, die wir
aufrufen, OnClick
Add-To-Do
Das loggen wir jetzt einfach mal
und gucken, ob das funktioniert
Muss das in Klammern?
Aha
Bam
Funktioniert
OnClick
Okay
Wir machen noch
Ich muss ja noch ein To-Do aufschreiben
Also ein To-Do zum Programmieren
Das klingt jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen
um die Ecke
Extra-Component
Wir machen da eine extra
Svelte-Komponente draus
für jedes To-Do, da können wir nämlich machen
For Each To-Do und dann können wir dann
hier drin sowas machen wie To-Do
Und so
Massive-Brain
Also
Leute, ich muss mal aufs Klo. Sieht kacke aus, ist bestimmt eine Enterprise-App
Ja, Enterprise-Apps müssen kacke aussehen
To-Do
Kacke-W
Also
Click-Button haben wir
Und wenn wir klicken, sagen wir
To-Do
Push
Und ein neues To-Do
Kommt dann da rein
Ist nicht so ganz
Funktioniert
Ah, das haben wir gestern gelernt
Wenn ich Arrays aktualisiere
Dann funktioniert das nicht
Dann
Äh
Was muss ich nochmal machen, wenn ich Arrays aktualisiere
Hier
To-Do sowas da
Aha
Ich musste Assignen
Ohne Assignen geht hier nichts
Ok, dann brauchen wir noch eine ID
Let ID
Fängt mit 0 an
Oh
Oder fängt mit 1 an
Erster ID 0 ist schon vorher drinne
So, Push ist dann
ID++
Ok, unsere To-Do sind schon mal am Start
Stimmt, stimmt
Leute, ihr habt recht. Die coolere Variante wäre
doch dann jetzt das hier, oder?
Also mehr JavaScript
Magic
Wäre doch, wenn ich das hier dann so mache, oder?
So?
Aber ohne Push
Alter, das sieht aber noch hässlicher aus
Da war die andere Variante aber schon
schöner, oder? Das ist doch
Das ist doch
eigentlich eher
Das ist schöner, wirklich?
Findet ihr ernsthaft, das ist schöner?
Ok, wenn der Chat das sagt
Wenn der Chat das sagt, dann ist das so, ja?
Der Chat hat ja immer recht
Haben wir ja schon oft genug gelernt
Und auch wenn der Chat nicht recht hat
Sieht unlesbarer aus
Also Poggers
Ok, verstehe
Übrigens soll ich euch noch mal zeigen
Wie nice schnell wir deployen können
Dann könnt ihr jetzt auch mal hier
den Button pressen
Aber vorher, wir machen noch was anderes
Also wir machen aber eine ordentliche Liste draus
Wir machen noch mal eine ordentliche Liste draus
Ul
Each To-Do
Als
L-I
Ok, nice, nice, nice
Alles klar
Style
Ähm
L-I
Oh Gott, das weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht
Ihr wisst das doch bestimmt, wie man den Punkt wegmachen kann
Point Style, irgendwas
Style
List Style
Ist das List Style?
Circle? Ja, ist List Style
None
Genau
Ok, huge
Beste To-Do App aller Zeiten hier
Was gibt List Style Type?
Warum gibt es List Style Type und List
Used
To construct default content of a
List Items Marker?
Ach, das ist die Abkürzung dafür
Verstehe
So, und jetzt zeige ich euch mal
Wie schnell man das ganze deployen kann
Einfach BÄM, Ansible am Start
Neues Gebilde
Neues Ding
Und App ist da
Zack, Leute, ihr könnt es jetzt auch ausprobieren
Ihr könnt jetzt unsinnigerweise auf den
Plus-Button drücken
Und dann kriegt ihr To-Do's
Ohne dass es was bringt
Wenn die Seite Refresh ist, wieder weg
Genau, Leute
Funktioniert es auf dem Handy
Das muss ich jetzt auf dem Tablet ausprobieren
Tablet
To-Do.kegw.services
Das ganze wird unter der Haube auf
Eine Hetzner Cloud VM
Deployed
Mobile, das ist doch
Also wenn das hier nicht mobile first ist
Dann weiß ich auch nicht
To-Do
Punkt
To, ich kann da mal schreiben
kegw.services
Jawoll, es funktioniert
Auch mobile
Richtig
Cloud-native, mobile first
Reactive und responsive
Alles hier
Wir gucken nachher noch
Wie wir Tailwind einbauen können
Ja, das wird
Das wird die neue Chira Konkurrenz
So, also was könnten wir jetzt als nächstes machen
Wir haben einen Add-Button
Vielleicht sollten wir das Ding noch mal ein bisschen
Bisschen besser
Stylen
So ein To-Do
Sollte doch kein Listelement sein
So ein To-Do sollte doch was sein, was man
Bearbeiten kann
Also eigentlich eher
Ein Input-Element da drinnen
Input
Sowas da
Hä?
Also eigentlich eher
Sowas da
Erstmal Dark Mode implementieren
Ja, das können wir machen
Dark Mode, wir machen einen Dark Mode
Leute, mein Wishlist Studio ist gecrashed
Mein Wishlist Studio Code ist RIP
Warum?
Hab ich irgendwas Verbotenes gemacht?
War zu innovativ, ja
Kill all
Code, bam
Window has crashed
OMFG, alter
Äh, das war's
Ansible, das war das hier, alles klar
Nehmen wir auf Webstorm, wozu?
Ich kann doch nicht bei einem Crash sagen
Ich wechsle meine komplette IDE
Alles klar
Wunderbar
Highly exquisite hier
Zu viel Elektron
Gut, das ist tatsächlich so
So, also Input
Jetzt müssen wir das irgendwie formatieren
Jetzt brauchen wir die 5-Hat-CSS
Leute, also
Was zeigen wir an? Wir zeigen an
Die To-Do-ID
Wobei die To-Do-ID interessiert doch
Eigentlich im Webinterface niemand
Wir brauchen hier eine Checkbox
Für To-Do ist erledigt
Input
Check, ne
So
Checkbox
Wir basteln das jetzt einfach
Irgendwie hin
Gestylt wird später, gestylt wird später, ja
Checkbox
Dann der Text
Und äh
Ein Remove-Button
Genau, genau
Ja
Trash, Trash-Button
Trash-Button
Trash
Ja
Oh wird das echt
richtig Augenweide hier style
So, Trash-Button
Nice, der Trash-Button
Warte, warte
Bisschen kleiner, 20
Das ist doch so nice
Jetzt brauchen wir noch ein Div
Was wir sagen Flex, dass das alles schön
in der Reihe nach ist
So
Display
Flex
Guckt euch das mal an
So
Irgendjemand ein Plan wie ich das hier
noch richtig ausrichten kann daran
Das geht mir Tailwind übrigens super nice
Die Sachen ordentlich ausrichten
Wir enden danach
noch Tailwind und machen das schöner
So, haben wir unser
Poggers-To-Do
Jetzt müssen wir noch den Text da reinbekommen
Padding
Ja, gut, das würde
funktionieren, aber das
wenn ich die Seite scale klappt doch dann schon
wieder nicht richtig, oder?
Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel
sagen würde sowas wie
Keine Ahnung
Checkbox, Style
A Padding
Pop
oder so
Ups
Geht das nicht?
Oder ist das
Margin?
Ah Margin
ist das
Wenn ich jetzt zoome, ah ne doch
Ok
Align
Item Center, oh jetzt wird's aber hier
Item Center
Ui
Guck mal da
Alter High
Highest IQ Chat wieder
So und jetzt kann man noch Spacing oder so
machen
Items, space around
oder sowas, was? Justify Items
Space, ne
Space around
Crit
Justify
Content
Space around
Ne, das ist
Kacke
Ok
So
Ah
Eine wahre Augenweide
Hier
So, da
ist es
Ok
So
Dass das hier sich nicht fokussiert
das kann man abschalten, glaube mit
User Events oder User
Pointer oder Focus oder irgendwas
Moment, wo ist mein
Ad Button? Hier
Select
User Selectable oder was?
User Select None
Und jetzt kann ich so viel klicken wie ich will, dann wird es auch nicht
fokussiert
So
Error
Unrecognized Feature
Juckt mich nicht
Ne, das mit
Pixel, das funktioniert, er ist schlau genug und skaliert das
ordentlich. Aber wir haben es jetzt auch nicht mit Pixel
mehr angegeben, wir haben es jetzt ja direkt
mit Center. Ok
Nice, also
So
Jetzt müssen wir hier den Krempel rein kriegen, da habe ich
schon wieder vergessen, wie das funktioniert. Warum ist
hier überhaupt so viel Platz daneben?
Warum kann das nicht, warum
kann das hier nicht unten drunter sein?
So, jetzt machen wir erstmal
den Break weg
Warum ist da so viel Platz?
So, weil mein List Item
liegt das
am Space hier?
Ne
Wie kriege ich das jetzt?
Wie kriege ich das jetzt auf der Seite
gesentert?
UL Style?
Wir haben eine wilde Mischung aus
Styles und Dings
Äh
Martian, irgendwie 0
Ok
Oder einfach nur 0?
Oder ist es jetzt das
Li, was da irgendwie eine Martian hat?
Ne
Panning?
Left?
Ah
Ok
Exquisite hier
Senior Front and Def bei der Arbeit
sieht man auch nicht jeden Tag
So, also
wunderbar
So können wir das lassen
Der Chat ist
schon wieder zu
feifert für mich
Was mich viel mehr interessiert, wie kriegen wir den Text
da rein jetzt?
Wie kriegen wir den Text da jetzt rein?
Also, was habe ich gestern
bei Asphalt gelernt? Wie ging das nochmal?
Lass mal kurz
überlegen. Nicht spoilern
Hier Chat, no
Backseat Programming
Lass mich mal überlegen
Bei
View war das jetzt View Model
Das geht nicht, also Bind
Value
Ach Moment
Wir sind beim Diff
Diff ist ja auch komplett falsch wo ich hier bin
Ich muss zu Input
Bind, Value
Und dann kann ich ihm sagen
Binde mal
To Do
Text
Und entweder muss ich das in geschleiften Klammern machen
Oder nicht
Muss ich in geschleiften Klammern machen
Aha
Okay
Nice
Das ist gut, das funktioniert schon mal
Jetzt haben wir den Text da drin
Jetzt muss ich
Also wir machen
Das Ding ist abgeschlossen
Wenn dann auf true ist muss ich
in den Häkchen rein
Wie kriege ich jetzt
in den Häkchen rein wenn es dann ist?
Also
Bind
Checked
To Do
Dann
Not Done
Okay
So geht es schon mal
Warum geht es so nicht?
Hilfe gucken
Das Welt
Checkbox
Das habe ich nämlich gestern übersprungen
Das habe ich gestern im Tutorial übersprungen
Weil ich gesagt habe, ey man weiß doch schon wie es funktioniert
Ist doch
Hab ich doch richtig gemacht
Bind Checked
To Do Done
Ach
Alter
Falsch rumgemacht
Nutzt man das Welt
Es gibt wohl eingebaute State Management
Ich habe mir das gestern zum ersten Mal angeguckt
Ich habe keine Ahnung davon
Sollen wir mal einen Bonbon futtern
Ricola
So
Da hängt was dran
Ist das
Ah ne
Das ist einfach nur abgesplittert gewesen
Okay also
Massive To Do funktioniert schon mal
Jetzt kann man To Do abhaken alles klar
Es sieht natürlich hässlich wie die Nacht aus
Nur falls ihr es auch mal ausprobieren wollt
Bitte deploy mal kurz
Also ich deploye
Kein Ding
Enzyme
Aber nicht Browser Refreshen dann
Guckt hier zack zack zack
Deploy und
Die To Do App ist am Start
Funktioniert die immer noch auf Mobile
Sekunde ich gucke mal kurz auf
Meinem iPad
Ja
Aber
Megabeschissen lässt sich das bedienen
Auf dem iPad mit den Checkbox
Das muss alles
Bisschen größer werden
Okay also
Huge Massive To Do App
Expanded
Brain
Ja es funktioniert auf dem Tablet auch
Aber es lässt sich kacke bedienen weil die Felder
So klein sind
So wir müssen das mit dem Löschen noch hinbekommen
Also
Add To Do
Haben wir jetzt hier
Und jetzt brauchen wir noch eine Funktion
Mit
Bewerbung ist raus
Remove To Do
Und jetzt brauchen wir eine ID
So
Und jetzt klicken wir
Den Mülleimer
Wo ist der Mülleimer
Ich blicke meinem eigenen Kopf nicht mehr durch
Ach hier das ist der Mülleimer
Wir klicken den Mülleimer
Remove To Do
Und kann man hier
To Do Punkt ID
Und wenn ich Glück habe funktioniert das jetzt
Log
Die Tailwind
Tausch auch noch rein
Hey guck mal es würde funktionieren
So und wie removen wir das jetzt
Wie kann ich was
Removen nach dieser komischen Logik hier
Wie remove ich denn da so was
Ok da bin ich
Da bin ich zu noobig für
All der 4
Die hatten aber auch ein Beispiel dafür
Svelte Array
Updating Arrays und Object
Hier
Add Number
Remove Number
You can use similar patterns to replace pop shift unshift
Ok keine Ahnung
Dann mach ich das mal so wie ich das mal würde
Filter
Element
Quasi
Alles
Wo ID
Ungleich ID ist
Bleibt drinnen
Es mag jetzt zwar nicht der
Was Idiomatic wie auch immer
Way sein
Aber ich hoffe das es so funktioniert
Easy
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf
Richtig gelöscht
Und easy
Easy
Dazu kann ich wohl sagen
Müsste nicht
To do splice ID 1 gehen
Splice macht doch irgendwas anhand von Indexen
Oder
ID ist nicht automatisch der Index
Was man da schon daran sieht
Dem Removen
Die ID gleich bleibt aber der Index sich ändert
Bewerbung bei Google
Ist raus
Ok
Falls
Gut
Da haben wir die Basics einer To do App
Doch schon immer da
Jetzt sollten wir die vielleicht noch
Ein bisschen hübscher machen
Leute ich deploy nochmal
Dass ihr euch dieses Wunderwerk der
Sveld Kunst angucken könnt
Deploy ist durch
M
Vorgass
IP? Welche IP?
To do Punkt KW Punkt Services
Jetzt Tailwind
Ja gleich
Tailwind Sveld Kit
Müssen wir erstmal gucken wie man das
Einbauen kann richtig
So
Welche Funktion
Braucht man da jetzt noch
Die Domain haben wir dem
Serious Max aus dem Chat zu verdanken
Mod Check einmal hier
Ohne den hätte ich die Domain nicht
Standard Text ist erstmal leer
Und Standard Text ist auch hier erstmal leer
Weil sonst siehts kacke aus
Was sollte beim Enterdrücken passieren?
Nix oder?
Ich meine das ist
Bissi klein oder?
Dann machen wir das nochmal kurz anders
Ähm
Wie kann ich das denn jetzt
Das sind immer die ganzen
Big Brain Flexbox Leute gefragt
Wenn ich das jetzt
Ok so
Und dann
Soll das Diff ja
100% die Breite haben
Nee
Wie krieg ich denn jetzt dazu
Dass das jetzt die komplette Breite nimmt?
Achso Moment das List
Das LE ist doch schon nicht 100% breit
Oder?
Ja gut
Das ist ja Hardcoded quasi auf
Hier
Moment
Das Input hat eine Standardbreite
Die sich nicht ändert kann das sein?
Das ist schon auf 100%
Das Input hat einfach nur nix
Was ähm
Ah
Guck mal hier
Das werden
Eine Übungstodo App
Guck mal hier
So gut
Also jetzt haben wir die Basics schonmal drin
Und das erste da schreiben wir hier rein
Prime, Sub
Ah ja ja
Ok
Eine wirklich
Komplette Augenweite diese ToDo App
So Style vielleicht sollten wir noch
Eine Sache machen und zwar
Ähm
Padding
Bottom 5 Pixel
Das wenn ich hier mehrere hinzufüge
Die ein bisschen gespacet sind
Wir brauchen noch ein Bild oder?
Kekstodo
Kekstodo brauchen ein Bild
Komm wir rippen mal kurz die Bilder
Beim Preischamp
Das da nehmen wir, Open Image
Wir rippen die Bilder kurz beim Preischamp
Woopog
Ähm
Kekstodo
Das Image
Jawoll
Jetzt sieht es doch gleich
Viel viel viel besser aus
Brandedit
Können wir aber noch sagen Style
Machen wir mal
Ein bisschen kleiner das ganze
50 Pixel
So
Und das jetzt quasi
Def
Haha
Ah
Massive
Padding Left
Alter
Das ist aber doch mal absolut Next Level
Oder
Haha
Porgas
So ist das doch nice
So wie packe ich denn jetzt das Bild
Ach ja
Wie kriege ich das denn in die Mitte von der Seite
Align
Self, Center
Nee
Wie kriege ich das in die Mitte
Text
Align
Center
Keine Ahnung
Justify Content
Justify Content Center
Oh
Es wird langsam richtig advanced
Also wenn das jetzt hier super
Wenn das jetzt nicht für die Google Bewerbung reicht
Dann weiß ich auch nicht
So
Also
Immer noch die Default
Schrift
Kicks to do
Wie kriegen wir denn jetzt
Den Kicks hier rein
Wir haben noch einen Static
Static Bild haben wir hier
Also
Move, Download, Wupp
Pog
Wupp, Pog
Repos
Kicks to do
Und dann Static Sauce
Nee
Static
Und wie kann ich das jetzt hier ordentlich referenzieren
Wie referenziere ich jetzt
Static Resources hier drin
Einfach so
Wupp, Pog
Ach wie
Das geht einfach
Also im Prinzip ist es
Ach
Ach der surft einfach das Static
Unter Slash oder was
Ach so
Alt Text
Benutzt keine
Blinden Leute
Die Poggers to do App hier
Oh was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen
Alt attribute
Okay ich muss es verwenden
Wupp, Pog
Image
Gut jetzt ich deploy das
Was ist jetzt
Ist aber ganz ganz schön
Hartnäckig
Bleibt es jetzt so
Gut jetzt wird mal deployt
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob das mit dem Deployen
Und den Bildern funktioniert
Oh deploy
Deployment ist raus
Hey
Leute
Wupp, Pog am Start
Easy
So
Wir haben eine to do App am Start
Wo kann man investieren
Du meinst in den CACW Services
Stack
Wie kriegt man eigentlich
Das Input Ding noch irgendwie ein bisschen schön
Das machen wir jetzt mit Tailwind wir gucken jetzt wie man tail
Wie kommt die PWA
Auch PWA sollte relativ easy zu machen sein
Manifest, File und Gutes
Ist da vielleicht sogar schon eins dabei
Nee PWA
In dem Fall müsste easy als Fax sein
Manifest, File
Den Wupp, Pog als NFT
Könnten wir versteigern
So
Also jetzt ist die Frage Leute was wollen wir als nächstes machen
Wollen wir Tailwind Styling machen
Oder wollen wir gucken
Dass wir das to do noch als extra
Component ausgelagert bekommen
Dass es nicht so eklig hier drinnen hängt
Style, Style okay
Gibt in Svelte
Eine Kapitel für PWA
Schauen wir mal schnell
Nee
Guck mal später
Styling
Wie kriegt man Tailwind da rein
Kein Schimmer
So da muss man wahrscheinlich in die Svelte
Config
Schau mal Svelte
Kit
Tailwind
Datenbank Connect da bräuchte ich hier irgendeinen
Backend höchstens
Ich könnte höchstens Local Storage machen
Ja das ist eine gute Idee
Das schreibe ich mir noch auf
Wollt ihr das nicht Highlighten
Standardmäßig
Local Storage
Ja
Gut
Add Tailwind CSS to your Svelte Project
Tailwind und Svelte Kit also zeig her
Ja
Svelte Config
Import Pre-Process
Svelte Pre-Process
Wat
Gibt es da eine offizielle Anleitung für
Ach guck mal da
Was ist das
Wo bin ich denn hier gelandet
Npx
Svelte Latest
Was bin ich hier sehen
Was ist das überhaupt
Was ist Svelte
Ah
Ist das so eine Art Package Manager
Oder sowas
Haben die nicht irgendwie eine offizielle
Haben die nicht eine offizielle Anleitung
Oder so
Vielleicht
Vielleicht soll ich einfach nur danach suchen
Keiner also was machen die hier
Import Pre-Process vom Svelte
Pre-Process
Hä
Und was da
Komm ich nehm jetzt einfach hier dieses das fertige
Das fertige Package und gut ist
Also
Npx Svelte
Latest Tailwind CSS
Alles klar
Gucken was passiert, oh ne nicht im nzf
Npx Svelte Latest Tailwind CSS
Vielleicht ist es vielleicht
Und hat es jetzt funktioniert
Und hat er das jetzt schon gemacht
Das hab ich doch da grad reingepastet
Oder
Oder waren die das
War ich das
Ah
Kann ich immer rückgängig machen ist vorbei
Achso Npm
Warum soll ich Jan install machen
Install
Ok
Starten wir neu
Das ist broken
Ah
Das ist broken weil die
Weil die Tailwind Defaults jetzt aktiv sind
Ok nice
Scheint schon alles zu funktionieren jetzt
Was ich kann jetzt
Ich kann jetzt mein hässliches Formatierungszeug
Wieder rausnehmen
Weil es jetzt standardmäßig schon
Hübsch gemacht wird
Ganzer Hammer umsonst
Ok also erstmal
Styling bei dem Image
Wieder raus
Aber hübscher ist es jetzt trotzdem nicht
Dark Mode
Wie ging denn Dark Mode nochmal
Stimmt das ging ja so gar nicht
Es gab ja kein H1 und so mehr
In Tailwind
Du musstest doch jetzt da sagen
Text
Ich brauch Tailwind
Plugin wo ist das denn
Extensions
Tailwind CSS
Intellisense jawoll
Das brauch ich
Text
Hier
Text 2xl
Jawoll da ist viel besser
Text 6xl
GachiBuzz
Tailwind hatte auch was für Images
Tailwind hatte auch was
Um Images richtig cool zu skalieren
Images
Scale Size
Object Fit
Irgendwie sowas
Object Fill
Object
Fit
Ah ne
Ist ja nicht Style
Class
Wie auch immer
Da bin ich zu noobisch für
Die Tore
Wie krieg ich das denn jetzt klein
So Tailwind wie ging das nochmal
Mit Dark Mode
Da konnte es doch automatisch
Switchen irgendwie, das war total easy
Das weiß ich noch
Modules Export
Ne
Einfach nur Dark
Schreiben oben
War das, war das so
Hä
War das einfach nur Dark
Schreiben, ne oder
Warte mal wie ging das
Das hab ich schon wieder voll verdrängt
Irgendwie das
Wie
Dark Mode mit Tailwind CSS
Ich hab keine Ahnung mehr
Wie das funktioniert hat
Also am obersten HTML
Ist das hier
Body
Also man musste nicht einfach Dark
reinschreiben, ne
Was da oben
Du meinst am HTML
Ne
Wie hab ich das, das hab ich doch schon ein paar mal gemacht
Wie ging das denn nochmal
Ne guck wenn ich da Dark reinschreibe passiert nichts
Das war total
Simple aber ich weiß es nicht mehr
Einfach so klar
Nein, nein, nein, nein
Wie war das
Ach doch das war doch ganz easy
Dark Mode
Wie ging das denn nochmal
Hier, ich mein jetzt die schreiben es ja offiziell rein
Glass BG White
Wie geht das
Wenn Dark Mode ist
Ja, ja gut, schön
Das ist das
Das wenn du standardlich Betriebssystem
Aber du kannst auch Sites und Supports bauen
Aber ich hab keine Tailwind Config
Hab ich eine Tailwind Config
Ach ich hab eine Tailwind Config
Ich hab eine Tailwind Config
CCJS was ist denn das
Config Dark Mode
Scroll runter
Ja Moment
Das
Das alleine hat es
Aber noch nicht ausgemacht oder
Außerdem hab ich das doch längst schon
Wie ging das
Sag mal hier
Exports Dark Mode
Glass
Dark Mode Glass
Das war
Ich hab das schon gemacht
Das ist aber schon ewig her
Das ist total easy
Du musst zwei Sachen einstellen und dann ging das
Tailwind Config
Exports gleich
Dark Mode
Ach so
Was
Unexpected Identifier
Nein das war total easy
Du musstest eine Sache einstellen und dann war das Dark Mode
Ich hab das schon gemacht
Aber ich weiß nicht mehr
Beim besten will ich nicht mehr wie das ging
Also so schonmal nicht
Theme
Nee Theme war was anderes
Ich hab keine Ahnung mehr wie es funktioniert
Wirklich nicht keine Ahnung
Das musste man nicht
Das war ganz einfach
Doku vorlesen bringt auch nichts
Wenn schon wissen
Ich hab das schon gemacht
Das war total easy
Du musstest zwei Sachen einstellen
Und dann ging das
Haben wir nicht noch
Irgendwelche Tailwind Geschichten hier
Wo wir letztens was gemacht haben
Irgendwas
Was haben wir denn da letztens gebaut
Keck WSS Service
Hat kein Tailwind oder
Dark Mode
Das hab ich doch längst
Das hatte ich doch längst
Dark Element hinzufinden
Das da
Das bringt nichts alleine
Muss man das vielleicht neu starten
Nein du musst da nichts setzen
Leute
Hört auf zu Backseiten
Wenn ihr keine Ahnung habt
Ihr habt genauso wenig Ahnung wie ich
Entweder wisst ihr das
Aber ich mein einfach
Doku reingucken
Und dann zwei Sachen in Chat posten
Ist doch für keinen hilfreich
Das hat doch so keinen Sinn
Also ich weiß grad nicht wie ich bin da grad zu dumm für
Ich krieg das grad nicht gebacken
Ich hab keine Ahnung wie man Dark Mode einstellt
Aber ich hab das schon gemacht
Ich weiß dass das easy as fuck war
Ich weiß wie es geht
Das waren zwei Dinge die du einstellen musst
Und dann ging es
Genau Media ist wenn du
Genau also das muss man auf jeden Fall machen
Ach musstest du nicht Dark noch dran schreiben
Ne das ist Schwachsinn das brauchst du nicht
Das musstest du nicht machen
Ach Moment
War das die Geschichte
Sekunde
Ich glaube ich weiß wieder
Ich glaube ich weiß wieder wie es funktioniert
Du musstest dem jetzt noch überhaupt
Eine Background Farbe setzen
So du musstest ich glaube das war es
Du musstest dem jetzt irgendwie noch sagen keine Ahnung
BG
E-Class
BG White
Ne dachte White wird dann automatisch zu dunkel oder so
BG Red
Ne wird nicht
Ich krieg es nicht mal hin
Ich hab ich komm und vergiss nicht auf wie du da in Dark Mode eingeschaltet hast
Ich weiß nur noch dass das zwei Sachen waren
Und dann ging es einfach
Jetzt hab ich auch Bescheid gemacht
Dass es schon wieder ultra kompliziert ist
Und ich werd noch nicht mal aus
Also gut das legt jetzt wahrscheinlich an mir
Aber ich werd nicht mal aus der offiziellen Doku schlau
Wie das funktionieren soll
Ich mein das ist
Du musst dem du kannst dem explizit sagen
Wenn Dark dann
Keine Ahnung BG
Red
BG Red
Kann das sein
Dass das irgendwas
Dass das in irgendeiner Art und Weise daran liegt
Wie dieses Plugin das eingebunden hat
Dass das nicht funktioniert
Dass da irgendwas verkehrt ist
Weil
Nein ich will Default Dark
Okay
Ja das ging
Aber das ging doch standardmäßig
Du willst doch standardmäßig
Man konnte doch sagen dass der standardmäßig
Dann alles auf
Oder bring ich das jetzt gerade durcheinander mit
Wutify
Ich glaub ich bring das gerade durcheinander mit Wutify
Weil da konntest du nämlich einfach
Ja ne Moment
Ich hab das durcheinander gebracht
Ich hab die ganze Zeit hier dran gedacht
Das ist ja was ganz was anderes
Lol
Ne
Das hab ich die ganze Zeit gesucht
Aber das war ja was anderes
Okay was haben wir hier im Chat am Start
Toggle mit Dark Mode
Zeig her
Jetzt okay jetzt bin ich auch nicht mal verwirrt
Das war was komplett
Komplett anderes was ich gesucht hab
Ähm
Das hat aber jetzt mit Tailwind nichts zu tun
Ist einfach irgendwas komplett anderes
Okay dann musste man das anscheinend doch
Dann musste man das anscheinend doch einstellen
BG
Keine Ahnung was ist
Was ist ein schöner Dark Mode Hintergrund
Ray
Sowas da
Ist das
Taugt das für Dark Mode
Aber ich bin
Das war trotzdem irgendwie anders
Man konnte das doch standardmäßig händeln lassen
Dass der auch drauf guckt
Dass der Kontrast standardmäßig schon überall
Passt und sowas
Was
Late 900
Ja
Ich bilde mir ein es gab was
Dass der dann auch drauf geachtet hat
Dass die Kontraste bei
Den Default Farben und so passen
Ich kann dir da nicht zu viel sagen
Ich bin nicht der große Frontendheld
Also ich hab View schon verwendet für einige Sachen
Und natürlich früher JQuery
Und die üblichen Sachen
Aber wirklich großartig was vergleichen
Kann ich nicht
Na gut dann lassen wir das
Dann müssen wir das wirklich alles selbst teilen
Aber ich
Vielleicht bringe ich es jetzt auch einfach
Komplett durcheinander
Aber ich dachte der hat dann auch selbst drauf geguckt
Dass zum Beispiel weil jetzt haben wir hier
Bei der
Bei der Schrift
Haben wir jetzt ja standardmäßig vom Kontrast her
Was was überhaupt nicht passt
Genau und das müsste ich jetzt von Hand machen
Weil ich jetzt
Bei der Schrift
Genau und das müsste ich jetzt von Hand machen
Und ich also
Ich bin mir da
Vielleicht bringe ich es auch
Vielleicht bringe ich es auch durcheinander
Ich dachte das konnte das standardmäßig
Dass du gesagt hast Dark Mode
Und da hat er auch drauf geachtet
Dass die Default Farben und sowas
Kontrastmäßig passen
Ich meine jetzt kann ich es quasi sagen
Dark
Text
500 oder so
So und jetzt ist es bei Dark ist es dann halt so
Aber
Hm
Okay aber wir machen auf jeden Fall erstmal Dark Mode
Dark Mode muss sein
Also
Gehen wir da hin
Ups jaja das habe ich jetzt
So und jetzt sollte doch eigentlich
Warum ist jetzt der Hintergrund nicht
Achso okay das muss ich wahrscheinlich
Jetzt auf Body machen
Glass
Und jetzt
Boah
Genau und
Jetzt musst du den Kram
Nämlich für Input und sowas selbst
Und
Das ging doch
Automatisch
Also entweder bringe ich das jetzt total durcheinander
Und ich mein was ganz anderes
Aber wahrscheinlich
Aber was ist denn
Was ist denn das für ein schöner
Text
Gray 100
So irgendwie
So
Nee
Nee Bootstrap habe ich eben nicht mehr
Verwendet das war wahrscheinlich wirklich
Und ich bringe es jetzt komplett durcheinander
Muss mal gucken
Gut
So also weiter im Text
Jetzt muss man den
Anderen Krempel stylen weil das sieht jetzt natürlich
Hässlich wie die Nacht aus
Preischamp ist beautify
Preischamp ist easy
Preischamp ist darkmode hier
Das ist beautify darkmode
Eine Option gesetzt und instant darkmode für alles
So also was haben wir als nächstes
Wir müssen den Keks
Irgendwie ordentlich anordnen
Wie kriege ich den Keks jetzt gescaled
Nebar Keks to do
Also
Style Text XXL
Object
Ne das brauchen wir nicht
Wie kriegen wir das jetzt angepasst
Dass das
Ach ja genau
So war das
So Dinger
Ja
Ja ja
Irgendwie so
Oh
Conquer S
Aber man konnte das doch auch irgendwie
Skalieren mit
Man konnte dem doch irgendwie sagen
Object Position
Tailwind Image Scale
Irgendwie sowas
Die hatten doch da irgendwas fertiges für schon
Scale
Hier
Sowas war das ne
Scale
Ja
Was für Scales gibt es denn alles
Hä
Und warum
Ist es jetzt nicht oben
Warum ist es jetzt irgendwo
Irgendwo in der Mitte
Line
Top
Weil man immer in der Lage das Image richtig aus
Auszurichten
Padding
Ne
Keine Ahnung
Aber so müsste das auch funktionieren
Aber das sieht doch eigentlich schon ganz okay an
Das sieht doch eigentlich schon ganz okay aus
Was
Align Item Center warum
Ja ja gut aber das
Warte mal wie macht man das mit
Tailwind eigentlich
Flex
Und dann
Display
Das ist auch nur geil wenn du es jeden Tag verwendest
Justify
Center
Hä
Das müsste doch jetzt das gleiche sein was ich vorhin auch schon hatte
Warum ist das jetzt was anderes
Warum ist das jetzt was anderes als das
Ach so ja ohne Semikolon
WTF stimmt
Justify Center genau
So
Ne ne das ist richtig
Align
Center
Items
So ging das genau
Gut
Dann machen wir die Farbe noch ein bisschen heller
Kicks to do
Und sagen dem hier noch
Das ist die Schrift
Die kriegt Padding Top
Und Padding
Right
Jetzt wirds advanced
Jetzt kommen wir mal zu diesem tollen Plus
Icon
Jetzt kommen wir mal zu diesem tollen Plus Icon
Der
Icon
Der kriegt diesen ganzen Mist weg
Aber ich glaube User Select
Können wir ausschalten
Select
Done
Gut
Padding
Bottom 4
Jawoll
So color
Text
Prey 100
Ja
So und jetzt konnte man doch
Wie war das Ring 2
Ne
Achso das ist das Diff
Oh Gott
Leute jetzt wirds advanced
Hover und Click
Animation mit Tailwind
Cool
Ging das vielleicht hier
Ne das ist einfach nur
Um
Das ist für Außentrum
rum
Wir können es auch einfach ohne Hover Animation lassen
Vielleicht wisst ihr was wir noch machen sollten
Wir sollten um das gesamte Ding nochmal ein bisschen
Margin drum herum machen weil das hängt jetzt
so an der Seite
Wir sagen jetzt hier einfach irgendwie
Margin 2
Ne Padding
Padding 2
Doch nicht
Oder hier
Wie krieg ich denn jetzt hier komplett
Ach es ist nur P2
Dann geht das nämlich auch hier oben
Ja
Genau
So ich deploy mal die neueste Variante
Da ihr das Wunderwerk der Technik hier
Auch mal
Wieder begutachten könnt
Wo sind wir jetzt hier stehen geblieben
CD, Ansible
Playbook
Bäm
RPA2 ist auch wieder
FUTIFY ich bring das jetzt
Export, Ignore, Host, Key Checking
Lul
So
Host, Key Checking ich glaub wo kommen wir denn da hin
Ok können wir mal gucken
Zack
Leute
Huge
So jetzt können wir das ein bisschen anders
stylen also dieser Button ist
eigentlich auf dem Tablet ein bisschen klein
Der ist auf dem Tablet viel zu kleiner Button
Der kriegt man auf 12
Jetzt schon besser
Ach so
Deploy
Guck mal hier
Huge Button
So und jetzt müssen wir
Inputs und sowas ordentlich
stylen da gibt es da hat Tailwind
extra
Hab ich letztens Forms
Da hab ich letztens erst einen Webcast
von denen drüber gelesen
Wie das
Dass man Forms
besser stylen kann jetzt
Ok
Form
Ne das brauchen wir nicht
Rounded
Ich copy paste mir das mal
Mal gucken wir mal wie das ausschaut
Du bist aber doch auf Tailwind V1
Wie kommst du darauf
Ich weiß nicht auf welcher
Tailwind Version bin ich denn was hat dieses Ding hier
Was hat diesen Kram hier
Ach so
Bei den Docs Ach so stimmt
Ne V2 ist
Ja
Oder V3
Stimmt
Jaja
Dark Mode
Da wird sich aber wahrscheinlich
nicht großartig was
Ne guck mal da hat sich nicht großartig was
Hat sich auch in V3 07 nicht großartig was dran geändert
Ist immer noch das
Gleiche
So also jetzt gucken wir mal ob wir das
Input ordentlich gestylt kriegen
Input
Zeig ich mal her
Plus
Und jetzt
Ach Moment das ist die Checkbox
Die ich gerade gestylt hab
Falsche das da
Hä wo hab ich denn jetzt gerade was rein
Copy Pasted
Ahja okay das ist vielleicht
Ein bisschen groß oder was mein ihr
Könnte vielleicht ein bisschen
Irritierend sein wenn das so fett ist
So schon besser rounded
Rounded ist immer gut
Margin 2
Ach ne es ist Margin 2
Padding 2
Padding 1
Reicht wahrscheinlich
So sehr schön
Any Primers
So das sieht doch schon mal ganz gut aus
Jetzt müssen wir das natürlich noch
Dark Mode entsprechend irgendwie
Anders stylen
Das sieht ja bescheuert aus wenn
Der Hintergrund
Also der Hintergrund müsste wahrscheinlich
Etwas leichteres Grau sein
Also quasi entsprechend zu
Was hatten wir hier für eine Farbe
Das da
Das wir das einfach ein bisschen heller machen
Oder dunkler irgendwie dass sich das
Abhebt
So
Das heißt
Kann man das
Das kann man rausschmeißen man könnte
Full gehen hier ne
Ja genau so war das sehr gut
BG White
BG Grey
Gut das ist Mist
So da sagen wir es nicht BG Grey
So irgendwie 600
Das sieht sogar relativ angenehm aus
Weil das ist jetzt kein
Kein Styling Wunder oder so
Ring 2
Hat man hier immer
Was drum herum
Grey
Wer ja
Wie konnte ich dieses
Outline nochmal ausschalten
Outline 0 oder so ne
Outline
Hinten
Ne
Outline 0
Ja
Wobei das mit dem Outline
Ist eigentlich gar nicht mal so blöd oder
Wenn man dann sagt Outline
Dann machen wir das anders lassen wir das hier weg
Sagen wir Outline
Outline
Grey
oder 900
Hä
Outline
Ne das da bin ich jetzt zu
Knubig für
Ist das irgendein Hover Effekt
Muss ich dann sagen Hover
Hover
Outline Grey 900
Outline
So ging das doch glaube ich gescheit oder
Ja genau
Dann klappt das nämlich
Ok das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht das schönste
Ok man erkennt sogar ein bisschen was
Poggers Dark Mode
Was ist denn da eine schöne
Textfarbe für schwarz passt nicht so gut
Wie sieht es denn da aus jetzt mit
Wir machen erstmal das Icon
Wir machen erstmal das Icon hier zum
Zum löschen hinten
Icon zum löschen
Kriegt das gleiche wie das hier oben
Und das hier oben hat
Text
Grey
Ne
Warte mal
Das da
Select
Wo ist der
Wo ist der Mülleimer
Hier
Glass
Aha
Ne ne das brauchen wir nicht
Komm mal jetzt erkennt man
Sogar was
So wie stylt man jetzt die Checkbox
Gescheit
Da müssen wir jetzt wirklich mal eine coole Checkbox
Das ist mir zu noobig dafür
Ich mein der Rest sieht doch jetzt schonmal
Ganz brauchbar aus oder
Der Rest ist doch ganz in Ordnung
Kann man bestimmt noch schön aber das für
Erstmal deployen
Leute gleich mal checken
Ob alles da ist
Bam hier
Wir machen es
Man könnte noch machen wenn man Enter drückt
Gibt es ein neues To Do oder sowas
Das kann man
Das kann man doch direkt benutzen jetzt
So
Was gibt es denn als nächstes
Das ist die Checkbox, die Checkbox muss ordentlich gemacht werden
Diese Checkbox ist mega hässlich
Vielleicht kriegen wir sogar
Irgendeine nice Sveld
Checkbox Animation hin
Sveld Checkbox
Animation
Okay das ist vielleicht auch
Etwas advanced
Neues To Do und Altes Sperren
Ja sowas wie bei Enter
So die Checkbox muss auf jeden Fall
Tailwind Checkbox
Ach ne das kann man
Teilen wie
Tailwind
Forms
Das muss größer werden
Ja ja ich hab es bei mir gesehen
Forms
Checkbox
Class Rounded Text Pink
Yes Text Pink
Das brauchen wir für die Checkbox
Class
Na aber so viel ist da eigentlich nix
Die ist jetzt weder rounded
Noch ist die
Alter es ist mal
Was ist denn das für eine Kacke
Den mal in Rachel Studio die ganze Zeit ab
Was ist denn das
Warum
Also ich hab das vielleicht innerhalb
Von den letzten
3-4 Jahren wo ich das
Was weiß ich
Das Thema abgekackt oder so
Ja unter Windows wäre das garantiert nicht passiert
Kappa HD
Backage ja wir haben gestern
Gestern haben wir alles geupdatet
Ja
So
Jetzt hab ich vergessen was ich machen wollte
Die Checkbox warum ist die Checkbox
Jetzt nicht gestylt
Guck mal hier Input
Da hat sich nix geändert
Ach Moment
Ich soll Tailwind Forms verwenden
Was
Tailwind Typograph
Wie krieg ich das in die
Config
Learn more about forms plugin
Oh super
Require Tailwind Forms
Machen wir einfach
Easy
Plugins
Muss man das
NPM installen vorher
Ja
NPM
Lass mal hier an die richtige Stelle
Warum hab ich eigentlich nix auf
Repos
Ach da ohne
Ja
Ich hab das in die
Config eingetragen das reicht anscheinend nicht
Cannot
Cannot find module
Muss ich das
Muss ich meinen Server neu starten
Nö Ups
Warum nicht
Doch ich muss das bestimmt installieren
Muss das bestimmt
NPM installen
Ok
Muss ich nochmal neu starten jetzt
Ah
Jetzt ist es pink
Jawoll
Endlich
So wollte ich das die ganze Zeit schon haben
Eine pinke Checkbox
Poggers
So und das müssen wir jetzt aber
Bisschen größer machen also
Outline
Kommt weg
Rounded
Ok
So size
Fette
Huge Checkbox
In welcher DB
Ich speicher die nirgendswo
Wenn du die Seite refreshst ist wieder weg
Vielleicht machen wir noch Local Storage gleich
So
Huge Checkbox
Kann man noch irgendwie hover
Dass ich irgendwie
Dieses
Active oder ist das
Fokus
Fokus oder irgendwas
Wie kriege ich diese blaue
Rande da drum herum weg
Weg
Wo kommt der überhaupt her
So
So die Checkbox
Was kriegt die für einen Hintergrund
Dark
BG
Das kriegt die gleiche
Hintergrund wie das da
Da haben wir nämlich
Hier
Das da
Kriegt die gleiche wie der Rest
Genau
So jetzt kann man checkboxen
Ich mein ganz ehrlich wisst ihr was
Dieses pink sieht mit diesem blau
Gar nicht mal so schlecht aus
Warum ist der Text eigentlich
Nur pink
Solange die aktiv ist
Warum ist die
Ansonsten
Ist sie grau
Die ist nur pink wenn die
Fokussiert ist
Die ist nur beim hovern
Pink
Warum eigentlich nicht
Ich finde das gar nicht so schlecht
Ich finde das sogar ganz gut
So
Meint ihr das ist ein shadow
Also mich würde auch mal interessieren
Wie ich dieses komische blaue zeugs
Da drum herum weg kriege
Fokuss
Ach Fokuss
Jetzt ist weg
Jetzt hat es einfach nur andere farbe
Alter
CSS ist so pains champ
Fokuss
Shadow
Alter CSS
Ich lasse es jetzt einfach so
Ist doch egal
Sieht eigentlich ganz ok aus
So
Fokuss
Was muss man
Was muss man denn jetzt noch machen
Jetzt kann man den kram schließen
Man kann den kram löschen
Man kann sich neue adden
Man kann das wieder abnehmen
Wir können das noch durchstreichen
Da können wir nämlich nochmal ein feature testen
Wir können das durchstreichen
Wenn das abgehakt ist
Also sprich
Wenn
Das testen wir jetzt mal
Wie macht man
Durchgestrichen
In Talents
Underline wird es ja wahrscheinlich nicht sein
Cross
Ne wie heißt denn das
Overline
So was gibt es
Overline so was gibt es
Strike
Line through
Alter da musst du erstmal drauf kommen
Sehr schön
Und das wollen wir jetzt allerdings
Nur
Wie machen wir das dynamisch
Class
Ne
Bind class
Hmm
So
Line through gleich
True
Ok
Das heißt das nur wenn
To do dann ist
Haha guckt euch das mal an
Pogchamp
Pifat time
So line through nur wenn es
Dann ist
Den Input sperren das ist auch eine gute
Idee
Bind read only
Read only
Wenn to do
Dann ist
Müssen wir das eigentlich nicht so machen
Oder ist es jetzt egal ob man das quoted
Da ist es nicht
Egal ob man das
Read only
Is not valid binding
Ehm
Ok
Is this read only
Einfach das Bind
Achja klar ich kann read only auch nicht
Two way bind und deswegen funktioniert das nicht
Das stelle ich mir ganz schön
Arbeitsintensiv vor das
Wie die das im Hintergrund checken
Ok also Programmiertechnisch
Bei denen stelle ich mir das echt kompliziert vor
So to do
Dann read only
So dann sollten wir die Sache vielleicht noch ein bisschen dunkler
Machen also quasi sowas hier
Sagen wir mal nicht
Cray 400 sondern irgendwie
700 wenn das
Gehakt ist
Wie kriege ich denn das
Außen drum herum weg
Shadow
Null
None
Was
Was ist das hier
Außen drum herum
Dieses
Was ist hier außenrum
Komische
Weiße da
Weil wir können jetzt ja noch was wir können nämlich sagen
Class
Uhhh
Class Dark
BG
Hm
Wie mache ich denn das jetzt abhängig
Davon
Border stimmt vielleicht
Ist ein ganz normaler Border
Border Zero
Ja das ist ganz normaler Border
Pok Pok Border
Hier genau
Das ist ganz normales ne
Ja
Wobei ich das mit dem Border an sich eigentlich gar nicht so blöd finde
Dankeschön Panda2
Border
Border 2
Ja Border 2 ist gut
Border
Irgendwie sowas
Nee das sieht auch das sieht das sieht doof aus
Ray
Irgendwie so
Ja bleibt jetzt so
Any Primers
Wobei das wobei das natürlich
Mit der mit der schwarzen Schrift gefällt mir immer noch nicht wirklich gut
Ja
Schrift gefällt mir immer noch nicht wirklich gut
Irgendwie Text
Text
White
Ray
Ja das ist eigentlich schon besser
Text Bold
Oder einfach nur Bold
Text
Wie macht man das wie macht man das fett
Ah nee XL
Muss aber scheiß
Nee
Elwind
Text Bold
Font White
Font
Bold
Ach nicht Text das ist Font Bold
Nicht Text Bold
Das muss man einfach wissen
Any Primers
Nice
Hier wirds durchgestrichen
Hier wirds gelockt
Und jetzt sagen wir ihm
Wir wollen
Wenn es dann ist
Wenn es dann ist machen wir
Das ganze
BG
Das muss ja dunkler werden 900
Ey Leute ich nehm normalerweise 900
Das sieht viel besser aus
Das sieht ja viel besser aus jetzt
Guckt euch das mal an
So kann man sogar richtig erkennen
Ok ich bin zu blöd dafür
Den Hintergrund dunkler zu machen
Wenn das To Do drinne ist
Das sieht sogar eigentlich ganz gut aus
Any Primers
Wie ich jetzt natürlich den
Den Kram dunkler machen kann
Das check ich doch nicht
BG Cray
Also ich mein an sich
Funktioniert das
Ich kann das nicht doppelt
Ich kann nicht mehrfach angeben
Ich kann jetzt nicht
Ich kann jetzt nicht hier drinne
Das heißt ich muss jetzt quasi sowas angeben
Das geht aber bestimmt
Das geht aber bestimmt schöner
Als das wie ich das jetzt gemacht hab
Guckt weil
Jetzt muss ich das ja doppelt
Reinschreiben
Ich weiß ja nicht
Ich bräuchte jetzt sowas
Ich bräuchte jetzt sowas wie
Das hier im Endeffekt
Aber
Ich weiß jetzt nicht wie das funktioniert
Kannst du das
Durchgestrichen noch animieren
Das wäre natürlich richtig poggers
Wenn du animieren könntest das hier durchgestrichen
Geht mit Sicherheit irgendwie
Aber das sehe ich mich aktuell noch nicht in der Lage zu
Dark BG Cray
Kriegt es hier
Checkbox
Ja
Das ist eigentlich ganz nice
Du würdest nur die Schriftfarbe ändern
Nö ich find das so eigentlich ganz gut
So ich push das mal
Push Champ
Ansible
Da könnt ihr euch jetzt auch mal ein Bild davon machen
Wie es jetzt aussieht
Und übrigens wir hosten das ganze
Das ist doch schon gleich
Das ist doch schon gleich viel nicer
Guck mal man kann sogar leere Dinge abhaken
Was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen
Wir hosten das ganze übrigens in der Hetzner Cloud
Mit einem Hetzner Load Balancer
Und einer Hetzner virtuellen Linux Kiste davor
Wenn ihr das auch mal ein bisschen ausprobieren wollt
Könnt ihr jetzt
Ausrufezeichen Hetzner im Chat machen
Und euch einen 20 Euro Gutscheincode sichern
Der geht nur noch
einzulösen
Bis 31.12
Ich denke mal wenn ihr ihn davor
Einlöst
Dann könntet ihr das Guthaben auch behalten
Aber ihr müsst ihn bis zum 31.12
Eingelöst haben
Und ihr könnt zum Beispiel schon
Eine Triple Core
Kiste für 8,21 Euro
Im Monat euch holen
Und also quasi von den 20 Euro Startguthaben
Fast 3 Monate lang
Eine Triple Core Kiste betreiben
Und ich meine
Mit 3 virtuellen CPU Kern
4GB RAM
20G
Disk Space
Kann man schon einiges machen
Ja und das ganze gilt nur für
Neukunden
Aber es gibt ja Mittel und Wege
Man kann leere Textfelder abhaken
Ja warum nicht
Vielleicht hat ja jemand einfach keine To Do's
Heutzutage und möchte die abhaken
Was mach ich heute? Nichts
Kann doch sein
To do nothing
Nothing
Ich muss sagen das Ding sieht optisch
Gar nicht mal so schlecht aus
Also ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass da was rauskommt
Was sogar annehmbar irgendwie ausschaut
Beim Plus müsste noch automatisch
In das neue Feld rein springen
Du meinst so
Ja das müsste man tatsächlich
Machen
Das wäre nicht schlecht
Wie?
Da fehlt mir jetzt
Bei Tailwind
Bei Svelte
In View hätte ich wahrscheinlich das
Geedet
Oder sowas
Das Plus halt unten rechts hin
Wie vorhin vorgeschlagen wäre auch cool
Ihr meint Plus so wie bei Android unten
Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Idee
Das machen wir jetzt als erstes
Add to do
Das kommt da nicht oben links hin
Sondern unten so als Floating
Man könnte ja hier immer mehr
Eindingsen und es sollte einfach
Immer oben drüber
Floaten
Das machen wir jetzt gleich mal
Plus
Wo sind wir denn hier?
Wo ist denn hier das Plus? Da
Also
Das heißt
Dann nehmen wir das Diff
Und sagen da
Haben die sowas wie Floating?
Also normalerweise würdest du da jetzt sagen
Absolut
Du sagst nicht eigentlich Absolut
Du sagst glaube ich Fixed
Fixed
Und dann Top
Du sagst Right
Hier
Und Bottom
4 oder sowas
Genau und wenn du jetzt neue Sachen
Hinzufügst
Dann ist es immer unten
Links. Wobei das jetzt natürlich
Durchsichtig ein bisschen doof aussieht
So minimal blöd
Track und Top werde ich
Garantiert da nicht mal einbauen
So da müssen wir noch einen Hintergrund machen
Also das Diff
Das kriegt jetzt noch ein
BG
Der hässlich aus
Das hier
Kriegt ein BG oder?
Ja das sieht kacke aus
Moment wie kriege ich das jetzt hin
Dass das nur ein Kreis ist
Hell ist grün
Green
Ach vielleicht nicht ganz so
Ekel
Das ist gut
Aber
Ja stimmt wir müssen einfach
Border
Rounded
Hey das sieht gar nicht schlecht aus
Leute soll ich einfach was sagen das sieht gar nicht übel aus
Ich musste mal kurz
Niesen Leute
Nein das ist nicht Bootstrap
Das ist eine Kombination von
Svelte
Oder Svelte
Als JavaScript Framework
Und Tailwind CSS
Für Styling
Aber alles was du hier siehst
Ist weil ich ein totaler Noob
In beiden Technologien
Ich habe keine Ahnung was ich mache
Keine Ahnung
Wieso ist doch mit löschen
Ist doch ok
Das ist bei Android Apps übrigens auch so
Das nervt mich bei Android Apps auch manchmal
Dass der löschen Button unten drunter ist
Unter diesem komischen Floating Button
Aber da machst du halt nichts
Das ist halt die Logik so
Wie groß ist denn der Button
Auf Mobile
Lasst mal kurz checken
Naja
Bisschen größer könnte es sein oder
Soll ich euch mal was richtig cooles zeigen
Was man da auch noch machen kann
Wobei ich mir jetzt da
Nicht ganz sicher bin ob das in Tailwind
Auch so easy war
Man kann hier nämlich sowas einstellen
Sobald das ein Small Display ist
Passt mal auf
Jetzt wird es richtig richtig
Six-Hat-Time
Moment wo ist mein Button
Der Button ist oben
Hier was man jetzt sagen kann
Ist folgendes
Wenn das Display Small ist
Dann
Das ist nicht SM
Wenn das Display Small ist
Dann wollen wir das größer haben
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
Ab wann ein Display Small ist
Ehrlich gesagt
Wann?
Play Small ist ehrlich gesagt
Ah guckt, Moment, ne ach warte, Moment der Breakpoint, der Breakpoint ist umgedreht
Das ist nicht ab dann, das ist ab dann aufwärts
Also sprach ich quasi so alles
Ne warte mal, wie rum war das LG?
LMG legit?
Wait a minute
Hm, bin ich grad verwirrt
Was gab's denn noch mal für Größen? Es gab SM
Warte mal, Tailwind Size, SM MD LG, ne?
Responsive Design, genau
SM Minimum
Ah, okay, okay
Das heißt, ich muss es standardmäßig größer machen
Ich muss es standardmäßig größer machen und dann sage ich ab, ne, nimm noch mal, ab, ab, ab, ab, keine ahnung, mittlere Größe ist es
Äh, ach so, MD
Am mittleren Größe wird's dann wieder kleiner, so irgendwie
so irgendwie ist ja so dass es dann quasi auf auf irgendwelchen kleinen displays schön
fett ist
irgendwie so und auf normalen displays aber eigentlich müsste es umgedreht sein oder
nicht müsste es da umgedreht sein das darf auf kleinen displays ruhig klein sein aber
auf großen displays darf es ein bisschen größer sein irgendwie so
so ich muss mir das mal kurz auf meinem handy kurz angucken ob das gescheit aussieht zeig
mal her also to do punkt keck weh punkt services also ich habe noch nicht die pleute achtung
high speed deployment es ist unavailable jetzt der lot der health check vom load balancer
kam gerade zum falschen zeitpunkt guck mal der health check vom load balancer kam zu
der sekunde wo ich gerade neu deployed habe jetzt müssen wir erst mal warten bis der load
balancer gecheckt hat dass es wieder da ist load balancer so jetzt sollte es aber wieder
gehen
ok machen wir das mal das sieht das sieht das sieht echt mobile technisch auch ganz
ganz brauchbar aus aber die seite zoomt auf ios wenn man zu oft klickt
das kann man sehen ausschalten das ist ohne scheiß leute das hätte ich mal gar nicht
gedacht das sieht wirklich ganz brauchbar aus damit hätte ich echt nicht gerechnet
dass da noch was rauskommt was auch noch halbwegs gescheit aussieht ja wir machen das pink hier
unten leute wir machen das pink wir machen pink 500 das ist das klar das ist das gleiche
wie hier oben pink 600 oder was haben wir da ne auch pink 500 hier massive style gründe
hier wie kommt mir das hier unten heller vor als
hier oben das ist eine to do list ja so exzellent haben wir was gelernt heute ok also next was
was moment was ist das mit dem zoom meta meta name viewport oh jetzt wirds aber big stonks
also wo muss das rein hier wahrscheinlich ist doch schon drinne guck mal das das alleine
ist es nicht dazu noch maximum scale user scalable null also so hier alles klar neu
deployen neu deployen reloaden auf dem smartphone gucken ob es funktioniert jetzt zoomt immer
noch zoomt immer noch wenn ich doppelt auf den doppelt auf den add button drücke wahrscheinlich
just ios things das kannst du bestimmt bei ios niger da brauchst du für ios brauchst
du bestimmt wieder extra extra tags dass es das nicht macht ja aber auf ios zoomt es
noch dass es da da mache ich jetzt aber nix dran es sei denn jemand von euch hat eine
gute idee so nice so next wo sind wir stehen geblieben
vielleicht muss ich das auf selectable non stellen das das teste ich noch mal kurz hier
warte mal das plus ist das hier class select selectable non vielleicht bringt das was
so immer noch was ist für safari chat big brain time user noch mal extra rein oder nur
hier hinten dran schreiben es wird der button wird nur auf dem größeren bildschirm größer
auf dem kleineren nicht noch mal ne ne moment user scalable einfach mehrfach reinschreiben
oder wie ist das ne oder soll ich user scalable no schreiben anstatt null so so und jetzt sollte
es nicht mal re-resize bei ios oder gucken wir mal das interessiert ios nicht es ist
egal was touch action und jetzt machen wir hier schon ios optimierung für irgendwas was
kein mensch jemals benutzen wird user scalable gleich no habe ich das habe ich ja so achso
ne ne das habe ich ja genauso nö das juckt das nicht ios gag wait das ist bestimmt irgendwie
so so just safari things wieder deswegen kriege ich immer anfälle dabei touch touch manipulation
gachi bus deploy gucken ob das jetzt was geholfen hat nö egal ich optimiere das jetzt bestimmt
nicht für ios so bleibt das jetzt nicht als class wie warum nicht als class das ist das
ist tailwind class da kommt das da kommt das bei raus touch action manipulation das macht
das macht das gleiche ok so was wollten wir jetzt noch machen leute wo sind wir stehen
geblieben local storage to do als extra component also to do als extra component scheißen wir
jetzt mal drauf weil ganz ehrlich das ist ja halt eins nur viel mehr gibt es ja nicht
außer eben die to do ist wie verwendet man local storage ordentlich gibt es gibt es da
vielleicht irgendwie ein wrapper oder so ne ok also local storage get item remove item
set item das heißt wir könnten doch eigentlich sagen bei jeder sowohl editieraktion löschaktion
oder checkaktion wollen wir speichern sehe ich das richtig oder wir speichern einfach
in einem timer alle fünf sekunden das ist aber doof aber ganz ehrlich damit könnte
ich leben weil normalerweise müsste man sagen hey bei einem adden speichern wir bei einem
removing speichern wir das sind deckle stimmt da wäre dieser krempel hier doch eigentlich
ganz gut da wäre dieser dieser dieser reactive kram doch eigentlich ganz gut von von swell
dass man dann jetzt sagt wie ging das jetzt nochmal dass man dann quasi sagt was weiß
ich blub gleich to do's ne moment wie ging das jetzt nochmal 12 reactive dollar sign
hier da double alles klar das will ich haben count to do's mal 2 ach nee moment logs to
do's jedes mal wenn sich ein to do ändert macht er jetzt führt er diese funktion hier
hinten aus ne also genau wunderbar das muss ich eigentlich hier jetzt bloß ein save drinne
basteln wie schreibt man da jetzt ne funktion drinne hier if so so guck mal so also das
heißt jedes mal führt das jetzt automatisch aus gut und hier kann ich jetzt speichern
also local storage wie geht der kram jetzt set set set item dann braucht man den key
to do's und da braucht man ein string also jason stringify to do's so oh local storage
is not defined wie warum nicht ah weil er das versucht auf dem server zu rendern oder
der versucht es jetzt auf dem server zu rendern und da gibt es das ja nicht
sch aids modified as well zweil wir somehow jetzt einfach danach
Aber on mount bringt mir ja nicht viel oder?
Kann ich den ganzen Kram in on mount reinschreiben?
Was Session?
Was zum Teufel ist Session Storage?
Session Storage?
Ich will Local Storage haben.
Ok das scheint zu funktionieren.
Wo konnte man sich das jetzt noch mal anzeigen lassen?
Local Storage?
Das war Application?
Storage?
Local Storage?
To Do's?
Ja, Any Primers.
Funktioniert.
On mount.
Jetzt ist halt die Frage, kann ich den Kram hier auch dann in on mount machen?
Also wenn ich das jetzt nicht on mount machen kann...
Vielleicht mache ich das dann doch so wie der Typ sagt.
You could try to check if it's really a browser environment.
Also quasi.
Ok dann lassen wir das on mounted weg.
Da gibt es aber bestimmt eine schönere Variante.
Alter javascript, if not gleich gleich undefined alles klar leute.
Was Modules App Env, siehste hier, der Chat wieder, absolut next level.
Import Amp Browser Dev Mode Prerendering.
Alter die sind ja immer richtig big brain, die Sveldleute, da gibt es schon vordefinierte
Sachen.
Also kann ich jetzt einfach sagen, if browser easy, oder auch nicht, achso Moment wir sind
ja in Javascript, wir brauchen klammern.
Wie das funzt, pock, pockchampus.
So bei jedem Update schreibt er das jetzt in local storage rein.
1, 2, so gucken wir mal, application, local storage, nope, warum nicht, ah das heißt
ich muss das anders rum machen, ich muss das so rum machen, ok man lernt ja nicht aus,
ich musste so rum machen.
Ok jetzt aber, 1, 2, 3, bum, bum, bum, 1, 2, 3, ah jetzt funktioniert das, ok nice.
Was wird gebastelt, ich lerne Sveld und wir deployen das ganze auf Hetzner Cloud.
Wenn du dir die aktuelle Variante mal angucken willst, geh einfach auf, geh auf todo.caqw.services,
da kannst du dir meine aktuellen Sveldbastelfersuche angucken, den Mülleimer müssen wir noch
ein bisschen groß machen, den Mülleimer müssen wir noch ein bisschen größer machen, wo ist
der Mülleimer?
Das hier ist der Mülleimer, remove todo, das ist ein bisschen sehr groß jetzt, so ist
es besser, Hoggers Mülleimer, was ist Sveld, das sieht nach dem JavaScript Framework aus,
ja es ist so eine Art JavaScript Framework, nur rot außen rum beim Eimer, das ist eine
gute Idee, on hover, der Unterschied zu Sveld und sagen wir mal View, React und Angular
ist, dass Sveld quasi beim Bildprozess sich quasi löscht, also das war, diese ganze Sveld
Geschichte, die man hier sieht, wandelt er im Bildprozess um zu Vanilla JavaScript, das
heißt du siehst gar nicht, dass es eine Sveld Anwendung ist, so wirklich im Browser, also
der kompiliert quasi seine Sveld Magic zu Vanilla JavaScript, was dann angeblich daraus
resultiert, dass die Anwendungen 30% kleiner sind und auch schneller, sagen sie selbst,
ob das jetzt so wirklich ist, habe ich nicht ausprobiert, also es ist mehr Magic zu Vanilla
JavaScript Compiler, die Idee ist eigentlich ziemlich, ziemlich schlau, ja wir könnten,
wir könnten den, wir könnten, on hover, also jetzt wird es aber langsam wirklich advanced
hier unser Zeug, wir könnten nämlich noch sagen, on hover, hover, Text, äh ne Text,
Text, Red, und wenn wir jetzt hovern, guck mal, wird der Mülleimer rot, Pink, ok, unser
Farbseam hier ist ja eher Pink, Pink 600, Pink 500, Pink 600, so, wir könnten auch noch
sagen hier dann Cursor, Move oder irgendwie sowas, ne nicht Move, Cursor, gibt es da was
gescheites für Delete, End, Pointer, sowas hier, dass man weiß, dass man irgendwo drüber
ist, so, GachiBuzz hier, ok, von der Idee her schreibt er jetzt jedes Mal bei jeder
Änderung Sachen in Local Storage, also das heißt, wenn ich jetzt nochmal gucke, sollte
er jetzt auch dann gesetzt haben auf Local Storage, Donen und es ist true, jawoll, das
finde ich wirklich gut, diese, diese Reactive Statements hier, das ist wirklich cool und
dass du hier verschiedene Environments importieren kannst, dass du gucken kannst, wo du gerade
läufst, ist auch ziemlich cool, da haben wir schon echt wieder was gelernt heute und guck
mal, wie nice der Button größer wird, wenn das Fenster größer wird, so, jetzt müssen
wir das natürlich bloß noch laden beim, jetzt müssen wir das bloß noch laden beim starten,
Local Storage, also sprich, to do's, jetzt müssen wir gucken, unmounted brauchen wir
jetzt doch, oder, unmounted, unmounted, Local Storage, da brauchen wir keinen Check, Local
Storage, Key kann man überprüfen, ob das da ist, Key, can ich einfach checken, ob es
ist vorhanden ist, get item, ach null, wenn es nicht existiert, ok, to do's, to do's
gleich, nee, Moment, ich muss checken, oh nee, warte mal, temp, wenn jetzt nichts besseres
ist, gleich, Jason, pass, sowas da, was für ein Ding, oder, oder, ach so, ach ja, das ist
eine gute Idee, natürlich, so könnte ich das tatsächlich machen, ja, ja, to do's,
oder, nee, nee, ich muss, ich muss, das geht so nicht, weil ich muss, ich muss doch, ich
muss Jason passen, ich kann nicht einfach sagen, muss ich, sag mal, muss ich das überhaupt
stringifyen, oder, oder kann ich da einfach Javascript Objekte reinschreiben, nee, das
muss ein Stringvalue sein, so, und jetzt haben wir hier else, to do's, das da, ok,
so, äh, jo, null, nee, cannot read null, ja, gibt nichts, ähm, Moment, warum funktioniert
das jetzt nicht, was ist, ach so, der schreibt das hier schon wahrscheinlich, der hat jetzt
ein leeres Array reingeschrieben, ne, ach so, äh, das ist natürlich doof, das heißt,
ich müsste jetzt noch gucken, ist das, was er hier gepasst hat, ok, ich nehme jetzt das,
was der Auskennfuchs da schreibt, das sieht äußerst advancedes Javascript Zeug aus, Jason
pass local get storage to do's, oder, wenn das null ist, dann ein leeres Array, ok, das
heißt, er kriegt in beiden Fällen ein leeres Array, so, ein leeres Array, und jetzt kann
ich gucken, wenn to do's ein leeres Array sind, dann das da, hä, das müsste aber jetzt
funktionieren, was steht denn jetzt in local storage drin, leeres Array, ok, was steht
denn jetzt in to do's drin, zeig mal her, to do's, to do's ist leeres Array, das kann
man bestimmt so nicht checken, oder, das ist bestimmt Javascript, da muss man so was hier
machen, oder so was, ach es funktioniert trotzdem nicht, kann ich, ich kann wahrscheinlich sagen,
to do's length null, ha, lekt, aber das sollte jetzt eigentlich nicht null sein, der sollte
das jetzt eigentlich, eigentlich speichern, macht er doch auch, macht er doch auch, warum
ist das hier, und warum ist das jetzt hier aber null, ich mein, es ist jetzt ja gesetzt,
ach so, wegen dem hier, weil ich's ursprünglich mal null, ok, das ist, das ist low IQ, weil
wenn ich jetzt was eintrage, dann, und reloade, dann ist es ja wieder weg, jaja, das kann,
ok, kann ich machen, aber das ändert das Problem nicht, das Problem ist, dass hier, ich muss
den jetzt, ich muss den jetzt irgendwie davon abhalten, das zu speichern, oder, set item,
und, so ist er null, ah, yes, sowas in der Richtung, ah, es funktioniert, also wenn jetzt
irgendeiner es zum ersten Mal aufmacht, kriegt er das so, nice, das ist bestimmt aber nicht
der Weisheitsletzter Schluss, so, was meinte irgendjemand, du kannst hier gleich das Default,
das Default reinsetzen, ja das stimmt, das Default ist im Endeffekt ja, das hier, also
quasi, Jason, meint ihr so, oh Gott, meint ihr so, also entweder findet er was, warum
nicht stringen, wait a minute, ich Jason passe das, Moment, jetzt stringify ich das um es
dann wieder zu passen, ok, das ist bescheuert, ne, das funktioniert so nicht, oder, wie soll
ich das denn jetzt gescheit machen, weil, weil das hier ist ja ein Pass, der muss ja,
hier den String oder da den String bekommen, und, ne, das ist das einzige, so wie es funktioniert,
aber das ist nicht schön, da fällt mir jetzt nichts anderes ein, da lasse ich das lieber
so, wie ich es vorher hatte, so, weil ansonsten müsste ich gucken, ob es null ist, ob es existiert,
oder, ne, das, ne, das kann doch so nicht funktionieren, ich kann doch nicht, ich kann
doch nicht, genau, das funktioniert nicht, ich meine, ich könnte so was hier machen,
ich könnte, ich könnte, ich könnte so was hier machen, aber das ist halt auch nicht,
auch nicht gerade der weisheitsletzter Schluss, man könnte so was hier machen, default, default
darf man das nicht nennen, ok, hallo, sowas könnte ich machen, dann, dann, dann passe
ich aber immer noch doppelt die Sachen, aber gut, man darf Sachen nicht default nennen,
sonst, to do's, default, was, das Sündags Highlighting laggt, echt, so, aber so passt
das, ich meine, das mag jetzt ein bisschen schöner aussehen, so, wunderbar, funktioniert,
jetzt machen wir das hier nochmal auf, wo ich es noch nicht offen hatte, man kriegt die
Standardsachen, ich deploye mal, ihr könnt mal ausprobieren, ob es funktioniert, also
wer es auch ausprobieren will, einfach hier, to do.caqw.services, was soll das werden,
eine easy, simple to do App ums Welt zu lernen, nix, was wirklich am Ende mal verwendet wird,
so, man kann sogar tabben, so, erledigt, erledigt, erledigt, erledigt, erledigt, erledigt, erledigt,
erledigt, alles, alles erledigt, alles erledigt, ok, und, man könnte, man könnte hier oben
noch nen Knopf machen, so, clear, clear to do oder sowas, oder clear, erledigt, so, irgendwie
sowas in der Richtung, aber das ist blöd, dann müsste ich hier unten noch nen zweiten
Button oder so hin machen, weil wo soll ich das sonst hier oben hin machen, fällt mir
jetzt nix gescheites zu ein, da müsste man, da müsste man hier oben noch so nen Header,
so nen Header, ähm, die erledigten nach unten sortieren, oh, big brain ideae, das finde
ich gut, die erledigten nach unten sortieren, das finde ich richtig gut, die Sache ist nur
die, wie sorte ich nen each ordentlich, du solltest das Laden nicht im on mount machen,
warum, progress bar, weil du so nie eine leere Liste speichern kannst, das stimmt, sobald
ich das wegmache, krieg ich wieder das Default Ding, aber das ist ja auch, warum nicht, das
stimmt, ich kann nie eine leere Default Liste speichern, weil ich es immer immer immer
fülle, was, lösche alle komische Zeichen, nö, was, keine komischen Zeichen, ne, hä,
ach ne doch, der speichert es doch leer, der speichert es als ein leeres to do, ok, das
ist natürlich auch nicht so clever, ja Bugs, Leute, also in Zeiten von Battlefield 2042
ist das ja nix, das bleibt jetzt so, das wird zum Feature erklärt und gut ist, jetzt,
ich will, ich lieber das, ich will als erst mal das sortieren machen, das finde ich ist
viel nicer, so und das sortieren sollten wir aber am besten hier im each machen, falls
das geht, world sort each, kann man da sowas machen, ne ne, ja das geht, kann man hier
drinne sort machen, sort, sort, javascript sort, wie funktioniert denn da kram jetzt,
ich will sort by, jas sort by, ist das paintschamp, ich will sortieren nach done, cool, sort
by boolean property, was ist das, gibt es da nicht einfach sort by, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ja, ok, ok, das ist ein Blenkit, ok, einmal die ausgeben nicht erledigt und einmal die
erledigt, oh das ist ne gute Idee, das könnte man tatsächlich machen, dass man das quasi
doppelt macht, einmal für erledigt und einmal für nicht erledigt, aber warum kann man das
nicht gibt es gibt es nicht sort bei oder sowas da muss es doch eine schönere variante
game array sort by he gets Mumbai
Was ist
Ich meine ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht ich mache da sowas wie
Sort bei keine ahnung element don oder so
Aber das geht ja anscheinend
Aha big brain funktioniert oder funktioniert das
Kunst
Stack overflow beste
Das ist tatsächlich ganz cool wenn es sortiert wird nach
Ja das ist cool das gefällt mir
Der sortiert auch die neuesten immer oben hin oder
Ja warum nicht doch ganz cool
Okay local so extra component machen wir nicht ich deploye noch mal
Leute fällt euch jetzt noch irgendwas a progress bar hat jemand geschrieben tut aber progress
bar geht aktuell nicht weil wir haben halt nur
einen status für dann ich meine man könnte eine progress bar unten drunter machen
Aber dann müsste man sich den progress in irgendwie noch speichern
Ach du meinst eine anzeige wie viel insgesamt fertig ist ja das können wir machen das müsste
eigentlich ganz gut sein das könnte man vielleicht oben hinschreiben
Dass wir irgendwie noch so einen header machen
Irgendwie hier unter fix to do dass wir hier irgendwie noch sowas machen quasi da
Irgendwie stats class was denn mal da dark text gray 100
Das ist dumm das müsste man eigentlich irgendwie ein bisschen anders anders anders schreiben
Dann und dann zählen wir jetzt
Gibt es sowas wie ein count direkt oder muss ich machen filter längs
Anscheinend muss man es doch so machen okay
If filter alles was dann ist null eins von
So Leute drei von sechs dohne
Und da können wir jetzt da könnten wir jetzt eine progress bar draus machen
Da können wir jetzt wirklich ein progress draus machen
Progress die progress bar also min null max reduce length quasi
Warum sieht die progress bar so hässlich aus value eins fünf
Okay progress ach komm lassen wir die schrift da weg
Color class text ach so wie macht man die color von der progress bar
Was ist die progress bar color für ein für ein attribute ist das bg
Ist das f gibt es was wie fg ne progress bar pink ja gute idee aber
Da müsste jetzt erstmal wissen doch die kann man bestimmt style progress bar
Color css color
Text noch noch text zusätzlich oder was text
Hellwind progress bar das kann man bestimmt style
Ich sehe überhaupt keine progress bar Ach der macht die selber
Ne oder css style Hellwind style progress das muss doch funktionieren
Ach warum ist das schon wieder so abartig
Okay dann dann machen wir jetzt mal kein hellwind da machen wir jetzt normales normales css
Progress width komm mal ob das prinzipiell funktioniert ja okay
Das das würde das würde es prinzipiell tun so color blue
Background hallo man kann die echt seriously Wollt ihr mich verarschen
Das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen dass ich so eine progress bar nicht stylen kann
Css tricks stack overflow stack overflow weiß sowas
Okay das das schockiert mich jetzt schon etwas
Und das soll jetzt
so im firefox auch gehen oder was ne im firefox gehts natürlich wieder nett
Okay dann dann machen wir hellwind progress bar
Ich hätte nicht gedacht dass sowas einfaches jetzt ein so advancedes ding ist
Kann ich nicht einfach nen range input dafür verwenden anstatt ne progress bar
Ich kann es doch faken ich kann auch irgendwie range input machen
Input range
auch nicht
Das sieht auch hängen geblieben aus
Okay progress bar stylen geht anscheinend nicht
Ja aber ich will das nicht mit dem diff selber bauen da müsste man das ja irgendwie scale
und so da müsste man dann überlegen okay dann na gut wahrscheinlich ist es mit dem
diff wirklich relativ easy wir setzen das auf 100 prozent weite
Okay diff okay class bg pink 600
Also die höhe muss ich noch setzen okay wunderbar
So volle breite höhe 4 rounded okay
So und jetzt und jetzt einfach nur wie viel wir haben oder was
Jetzt einfach nen child diff mit nem width percentage
Achso ich dachte ich mach hier die breite
Also machen wir hier null und dann sagen wir hier diff dass es hier einfach so rein wächst
Und dann sagen wir jetzt hier wie war das nochmal
Ich hab schon wieder vergessen wie man class binding macht so
Ach ne ne wir brauchen nicht class wir brauchen style binding
Style width gleich 100
Ne wie macht man denn sowas jetzt
Da muss ich das wahrscheinlich weg machen
Da muss ich das hier wahrscheinlich weg machen
Moment ich bin auch komplett falsch
Sekunde ich bin im Bild alter
Wie macht man jetzt hier komisches style binding
Wie funktioniert das jetzt
Das muss ja das muss das muss ja dynamisch machen
Welts style binding oder so
Binding dimensions
Ach so das geht auch also style gleich und dann quasi sowas hier
Width 100px
So das heißt anstatt 100px machen wir jetzt string interpolation
Sagen dann quasi was wir müssen wir müssen dann teilen
Durch Länge ne
Also das durch das
Jetzt wirds mir aber doch zu kompliziert
Wie string interpolation javascript so also das ist jetzt richtig abartig
Warte mal ne wir wollen den prozent haben
Wir wollen den prozent haben
So wir machen da mal oben ne funktion draus
Sonst plege ich nämlich da nicht mehr durch
So ein prozent wunderbar also function completion oder completed
Filter to do's Länge durch insgesamt
Ergibt doch Sinn was ich da mache
Was macht der jetzt hier für
Warte mal
Ah hier
Also was weiß ich ich hab 3 von 6 0,5 50%
Genau
4 66% ja ok das ergibt Sinn
Wo sind wir jetzt stehen geblieben
Pink
Ah
Completed
Ach null teilen oder
Ach ne ich hab jetzt krieg ich irgendwie ne null ich krieg jetzt da null raus
Also den muss ich sowas hier machen ne
Hä
Ach ne das ist jetzt ja nicht dynamisch ne
Das ist jetzt ja nicht dynamisch das muss ich jetzt ja wieder dynamisch berechnen lassen
Das geht ja an der Stelle gar nicht
Da brauch ich jetzt ja wieder sowas hier
Also quasi hier drinne muss ich das quasi berechnen lassen
Wenn sich to do's ändern
Oder ich mache ich mache nochmal neun hier completed
Braucht da gar keine function ich brauche dann
Braucht dann quasi wieder sowas hier zack bumm
Completed
Gleich
To do's filter durch to do's length
Das brauch ich
So und das sollte sich jetzt automatisch updaten
Das ist zu lang ich blick schon immer durch hier
Funktioniert prinzipiell
Äh mal hundert muss ich noch machen oder
Ja
Fogchamp
Aber das mal hundert mach ich da oben drin
Mal hundert
So und da kommt jetzt noch
Animationen Leute
Wir haben doch letztens gelernt wie man's fällt animationen
Wir machen jetzt animationen
Big big stonks animationen machen wir da jetzt noch rein
Ähm wir brauchen aber erst noch mal hier ein bisschen bisschen margin
Ähm oder padding top eins
Ne margin top
Eins
Gleich bleibt zwei
Ja das ist ganz hübsch
So ähm animationen animationen
Aber margin hat nicht funktioniert
Ne doch margin funktioniert doch habe ich doch ja
So ähm
Moment wie ging das jetzt noch mal mit den mit den animationen
Wo haben wir es denn hier
Forgas App
Oh ne jetzt hab ich das überschrieben ich kann nur
Hier
Mehr war das net ne
Cubic out
Cubic crossfade braun man net qt chat braun man anat
Duration
Procress set null ok
Wie habe ich das jetzt noch mal integriert bei dem anderen
Ach hier progress
Den hat man jetzt hier genommen
In progress completed ich hab nicht geniesort ich hab gehusstet
Ein Horst bedankeschön ich hab gehusstet weil ich schon seit
Irgendwie drei Wochen Halsweh hab
Zu viel gachibass
So progress
Ähm guck mal ich hab progress auf null gesetzt
Warum ist progress auf null
Oh die animation die muss jetzt muss jetzt noch sein
Value
Ach da muss man dollar progress machen
Dollar progress ist es ok
Dollar jetzt ist aber ganz schön nestet hier der ganze Spaß
Ok dollar progress und jetzt updaten wir quasi progress
Jedes mal hier
100 progress set
Das kann man wegschmeißen
Guckt euch mal huge animation an seht ihr das
Wie es krass animatet
Am Anfang ist es noch am Anfang ist es ein bisschen verwirrt
Weil es am Anfang auf 100 ist
Gibt es nicht sowas wie initial oder sowas
Warum ist es am Anfang auf 100
Am Anfang sollte es doch auf null sein oder
Am Anfang sollte es auf null sein ich setz es auf null
Wobei wenn ich das raus
Ach weil es null durch null to do's gibt
Meinst du
Nee aber ich setz den progress
Nee nee daran liegt es nicht
Ich setz den progress auf null
Keine Ahnung warum das standardmäßig hier ist
Wahrscheinlich einfach weil es noch nicht gerendert ist
Wahrscheinlich einfach deswegen machen wir das anders
Wir setzen einfach hier den kram am Anfang auf null
Und jetzt überschreibt er das guck
Sobald es unmounted ausgeführt oder das erste Mal aktualisiert wird
Saved ja
Wir können aber auch anstatt set null
Nee können wir nicht doch wir können den progress initial setzen
Nach unmounted
Ist aber auch nicht schneller
Egal damit werden wir leben müssen jetzt
Kann es sein das es an der Duration liegt
Es liegt an der Duration guck mal
Der interpolated quasi auf null runter von 100 oder so
Naja
Ich denke damit kommen wir leben
Was haben wir hier noch so zu Hause
Delay interpolate nee sonst gibt es da nichts mehr
Und das hier ist was standard value nee
Subscribed da kann man auch was wobald es sich ändert
Ok update
Nun gut das passt eigentlich ganz gut
Jetzt haben wir sogar eine progress ich push das mal Leute
Können ihr euch den wahnsinns progress angucken die wir gemacht haben heute
To do
Oh ach nee ist doch richtig
Alles erledigt und nichts erledigt
Seht nur falsch aus aber nee nee stimmt ja
Wenn ich alles lösche
Guck mal wenn ich jetzt die lösche ist ja klar dass es insgesamt mehr progress gibt
Weil es ist ja nur einer da
So und dann ist 0 durch 0 geht nicht
Das müsste übrigens einen Error geben wenn er 0 durch 0 rechnet
Null macht er nicht
0 durch 0 ist kein Problem für Javascript
Da kommt wahrscheinlich ein String raus 0 durch 0 in Javascript oder
Oder ein leeres Array oder irgendwie sowas
Das ist in Javascript ja nicht immer logisch
Was da für ein return wert rauskommt
Was macht Svelte besser gegenüber der Konkurrenz
Also der Vorteil also der selling point ist
Dass es kein Javascript framework im eigentlichen Sinn ist
Sondern ein Javascript compiler der quasi diese ganze Magic die du hier siehst
In vanilla Javascript übersetzt
So dass du gar keine Abhängigkeit mehr laden musst bei
Deiner Live Seite also sprich
Wenn du view wenn du in der view kleinzeit App hast
Da musst du immer noch Vue.js als framework drinnen laden
Dass dieses ganze reactivity Zeug und sonst was gemacht werden kann
Das brauchst du dann nicht
Das kompiliert komplett runter zu vanilla Javascript
So dass nichts zusätzliches da mehr an logik drinnen ist
Außer wirklich das was du brauchst das die Seite läuft
Angeblich führt das dazu dass die seiten bis zu 30 prozent kleiner sind
Und wohl auch schneller
Die machen auch kein javascript virtual dom geschiss
Ich denke es kommt drauf an
Ich glaube man kann das so pauschal gar nicht sagen
Dass es immer besser ist oder dass was anderes immer schlechter ist
Ich glaube da muss man im detail gucken
Aber unabhängig davon von dieser eigentlichen
Von diesem Alleinstellungs Merkmal
Die Handhabung finde ich auch wirklich gut gemacht
Da kann man sich nicht beschweren also es ist alles logisch
Es ist alles irgendwo irgendwo nachvollziehbar
Ist es aber bei Vue zum größten Teil auch muss man sagen
Bei angular kann man sich da vielleicht drüber streiten
Was ist denn in Javascript das Ergebnis 0 durch 0
Not the number seriously
Ja also Javascript kann 0 durch 0 teilen
Und was ist 0 geteilt durch 0,0 auch not the number
Das ist bei Javascript alles nicht so logisch
Oh das geht nicht
Und die große Frage ist jetzt
Was ist 0 durch 0 ah auch not the number ok
Ok und ist der 0 durch 0 gleich gleich 0 durch 0
Ah false natürlich was auch sonst
Das heißt not the number ist nicht gleich not the number
Na gut man weiß ja nicht welche number weil es ist ja not the number
Aber aber gleich gleich ist es bestimmt auch nicht
Ach du scheiße Javascript keine Ahnung wer das noch versteht
1337 das ist auch Javascript ist absolut abartig da durchzublicken
Es vergeht kein Tag wo nicht irgendwie neues gehaltenes Framework rauskommt
Wie würde ich denn jetzt checken ob not the number wirklich not the number ist
Gibt es sowas wie none to string ernsthaft
Das ist true das ist true was ist none ist none ach sowas gibt es auch
Ach du scheiße Egal ich will das gar nicht verstehen
Laut Spezifikation ist das korrekt das ist ein
Ach so warte mal das muss man das mag ja sein dass das laut Spezifikation korrekt ist
Sonderlich intuitiv ist es aber trotzdem nicht
Ich mein C++ ist auch lauter Spezifikation korrekt
Aber es ist trotzdem eine Ausgeburt der Hölle was da sich auch was die sich ausdenken
Okay hat noch eine irgendwie super 5 head Ideen was wir noch einbauen könnten
Ich mein für einfach so ein bisschen üben ist das doch cool
Bei der Gelegenheit mache ich gerade noch mal eine Runde Werbung
Übrigens Leute ihr könnt euch jetzt noch nur noch also quasi nur noch eine Woche lang
Bis zum 31.12. könnt ihr euch mein Hetzner Startgutschein sichern für 20 Euro
Ausrufezeichen Hetzner im Chat
Und mit diesem Startgutschein könnt ihr zum Beispiel schon fast drei Monate lang einen
Triple-Curse Server laufen lassen ohne dass ihr extra bezahlen müsst
Ding Sound bei der Checkbox, nee
Oder aber auch hier drei Monate das plus noch ein bisschen Storage
Man kommt mit 20 Euro Startguthaben erstaunlich weit
Wisst ihr was was wir auch noch mal ausprobieren müssen in Note kurz
Not a number ist die größer als not a number, false
ist die kleiner als not a number, false ist die gleich not a number, false
Alles klar Was ist sie denn dann
Sie ist nicht größer sie ist nicht kleiner und sie ist nicht gleich
Eins davon muss es doch sein Das type of
Geht es dann so Type of not a number number
Alles klar Achso um die Sache jetzt noch komplett zu
machen Ach das ist true
JavaScript weiß nicht so genau ist sich nicht so sicher
So hat noch jemand was was was was schlau ist zum einbauen
Weil ansonsten würde ich das jetzt erstmal so lassen
Hatten wir noch irgendwas progress bar haben wir gemacht
Noch mal deployen Mehrere Listen
Oh nee das ist das das wäre jetzt ziemlicher Umbau wenn man mehrere Listen haben
könnte ein bisschen wie nur Tabs oder irgendwas
bauen oder sowas Abige Einträge
Mehrere User mit login ist klar läuft nur lokal
Ich kann kein HTTP Request machen das funktioniert da wie überall anders auch mit Fetch wahrscheinlich
Aber ich habe kein Backend das Ding läuft komplett ohne Backend
Da gibt es keine Sachen wo man track and drop
Nee das ist zu komplizieren Das ist wirklich nicht ohne
PWA könnte man vielleicht das mache ich aber PWA könnte man tatsächlich machen
Aber das mache ich dann beim nächsten Mal in einem Stream
Suche Suche ist tatsächlich noch eine ganz gute
Idee Suche könnte man wirklich machen
Das finde ich ist eine gute Idee Suche
Welches Backend würdest du dazu nehmen ich würde einen ASP.NET Core CraftQL Backend
machen
Nee sortieren geht nicht Da müsste ich irgendwie noch eine Zusatzreihenfolge
machen oder vor und nachher und so das ist zu kompliziert
Filter erledigt nicht erledigt Na gut das haben wir ja im Prinzip schon dadurch
dass es die und die nicht ehrlich unten hin sortiert das mit der Suche das mit der Suche
finde ich tatsächlich Delete all Button das habe ich mir auch schon überlegt aber ich
weiß nicht wo ich den genau hin machen soll den Delete all Button
Wir könnten den Delete all Button oben neben die progress bar machen
Aber der Delete Button ist größer als die progress bar das sieht dann wieder kacke aus
Ich schreibe mir das mal auf
Delete all
Das kann man durchaus meinen Suche müsste tatsächlich relativ easy sein
Das könnte man sogar hier machen mit der Suche
Hier direkt drinnen einfach einen Sort und dann direkt einen Filter hinterher und gucken
ob das da drinnen steht
Hier unten
Das schreibe ich mir mal auf das machen wir nicht heute
Aber da haben wir vielleicht noch mal was für dieses Jahr
Ja das machen wir auf jeden Fall auch noch Komponent aus dem to do
Steuerung F überschreiben nee auf gar keinen Fall
Steuerung F überschreiben ist Zoomer Webseite
Ganz schlimm ganz schlimm
Kennt ihr diese Foren die Steuerung F überschreiben
So hier zum Beispiel so discourse oder sowas
Home Assistant Forum da sieht man das zum Beispiel schön
Ich glaube das ist ich glaube es ist discourse
Was ist das für ein Forum Leute ihr kennt euch da bestimmt gut aus
Das ist steht nicht da was es ist
Ist das discourse zumindest wenn ihr hier wenn ihr hier Steuerung F drückst
Kriegst du so eine kacke und nicht das da gut das funktioniert auch nicht anders
Weil es das nicht
Weil es das dynamisch nachlädt wobei ich da halt auch nicht verstehe
Warum und ich meine die Frage wirklich ernst
Warum ist das hier besser als einfach HTML mit Pages
Ist ernst gemeinte Frage was ist der Vorteil von diesem dynamischen
JavaScript Trotz wo du noch nicht mal deine Browsersuche verwenden kannst
Und alle alle furz lang beim scrollen irgendwas nachlädt
Was ist der Vorteil davon von einfach keine Ahnung 100 Posts pro Seite zu laden
Und dann unten erste Seite zweite Seite dritte Seite zu haben
Aber selbst auf mobile ist das scheiße weil du dir nicht merken kannst wo was stand
Man könnte es ja aber zumindest zumindest man ist ja durchaus in der Lage heutzutage
UIs zu bauen die unterschiedlich sind zwischen mobile und desktop
Aber das ist so beschissen das triggert mich wirklich bei jeder Seite die sowas haben
Es ist so ein Trend den ich nicht nachvollziehen kann warum der sich durchgesetzt hat
Dann lieber dann lieber die Poggers Kicks to do App verwenden
Viel besser und Prime-Sub-Star lassen
Und Ausrufezeichen Hetzer 20 Euro Startgutschein sichern
Also ich hab mir jetzt aufgeschrieben was wir das nächste mal noch machen könnten ist
Die Komponenten die to do in extra Komponenten auslagen
Mal gucken ob wir vielleicht sowas wie track and drop hinkriegen
Ich weiß prinzipiell wie track and drop im Browser funktioniert
Aber track and drop ist immer sehr sehr großer Paints Champ
Da musst du dann sowas machen wie Element anzeigen wo es reinkommt
Dann musst du dir merken was ist vorher was ist nachher das ist schwieriger als man denkt
Dann hab ich eine Suche aufgeschrieben und ein delete delete all button
Wer die Anwendung noch mal ausprobieren will to do.hackw.services
Man könnte zum Beispiel noch Shortcuts fürs Completing machen
Ich mein mal ernsthaft die App wird eh niemand jemand benutzen wozu auch
Es gibt tausendfach bessere to do Apps das ist ja nur zum üben
Shortcut könnte man noch machen Prioritäten könnte man noch machen
Das ist rein eine Übungs eine Übungs App ne also ich plane nie das in
irgendeiner Art und Weise erstens zu supporten zweitens soweit auszubauen dass es sinnvoll
ist
Einen Papierkorb vielleicht ja ist eine gute Idee
Papierkorb warum nicht
To do App ist halt super zum üben ich hab noch eine Idee
Ja progress machen noch bei dem progress machen wir noch ein Outline drum herum
Daß man es besser sehen wobei das sieht scheiße aus ne
Ne das sieht dumm aus oder weil so blöd sieht es gar nicht aus
Man müsste das den Ring halt komplett drum herum machen
Also quasi noch mal ein extra hier gelandet
Warum hab ich da denn im diff hier grade
So was hä
Ist vielleicht auch nicht schlecht an erkennt man wenigstens dass ein progress
Bar ist da oben
Und wenn es leer ist ja gut wenn es leer ist wird es halt leer angezeigt
Ja ist wahrscheinlich sogar besser value anzeigen
Value anzeigen müsste man dann hier drauf irgendwie schreiben
Spam oder so
Ne diff und dann glass absolute oder sowas
Text gray top
Wie kann ich denn das da jetzt sinnvoll drinnen platzieren
Das muss ich hier das muss ich auf relative stellen
Weil diese ausrichtung geht immer anhand des letzten auf relativ gesetzte element
Bottom
Wie krieg ich das jetzt gescheit angeordnet da
In der Mitte
Fällt mir jetzt bloß wirklich style ein
Minus fünf pixel oder sowas
Mein chill ist was anderes
Und da kommt jetzt rein
Dollar progress
Wow ne das ist dumm
Das ist dumm das ist die animation die man sieht
Ne das ist das ist richtig hängen geblieben
Ne das kann man so nicht machen
Das ist die animation die man jetzt sieht
Ne math floor wird auch nix bringen
Dann siehst du halt dass es irgendwie hier wechselt es soll direkt
Na wobei warum nicht
Aber wir können es mal ausprobieren
Dann fallen zumindest die hinteren dinger weg
Na gut dann sieht man jetzt halt wie es mehr und weniger wird
Ja auch okay
Auch auch gut können wir auch so lassen
Okay
Was war nochmal fette schrift
Das war nochmal fette schrift font bold
Ja noch noch besser oder
Das ist tatsächlich jetzt ganz cool
Das gefällt mir
Was haben wir hier für nochmal für ein background
Grey kurz kurz was checken
Pink
Oje es ist wieder abgekackt
Ich hab kein bob mehr
Warum ist mein wishlist studio so am abscheißen heute
Hey quake das kann doch nicht in ernst sein
Dass das so am abkacken ist
Doch das doch das ist doch kein witz los gerade
Ne so ist es nicht besser oder
So so ist schon besser
Oder hatten wir vorher gar nix
So hatten wir es vorher
Ja das not a number kommt am Anfang
Weil er 0 durch 0 rechnet wahrscheinlich denke ich mal
Irgendwo hier
Ja
Das ist weil er 0 durch 0 rechnet
Ich hätte einfach gesagt
So was hier
Ist wir haben doch jetzt was gelernt ist dann
Dann null ansonsten percent
Und direkt
Hoch
Habe ich jetzt irgendein bug gefunden
Okay ich pushe jetzt nochmal
Was die die prozent zahlen noch dahinter
Du meinst jetzt da dass man weiß was das für eine zahl ist
Okay das ist meine letzte abendzettelung für den stream jetzt
Ja prozent lehrzeichen oder ohne lehrzeichen leute
Ja nice
Die position in die mitte meinste
In die mitte ne ich glaube das irritiert wenn das in der mitte ist
Ihr style ist krollbar leute scrollbar style ist abfuck das habe ich schon mal gemacht
Das ist auch wieder so ein ding wo du sachen im claw machen kannst aber in firefox nicht
Im safari gerade auf ios schon mal gar nichts gescheit
Also ich kann es noch mal guck mal ich kann es mal in die mitte in die so ungefähr in
die mitte in die mitte setzen
Das ist wirklich in die mitte aber ich finde es in der mitte ehrlich gesagt irritiert das
ein bisschen es ist auch nicht wirklich in der mitte weil das irgendwie komisch errechnet
wird wo mitte ist aber ich finde es aber ich finde es am rechten rand tatsächlich hier
besser mit dem prozent
Ja nice weg damit so deployen
any primers
Alles klar so wer will kann er noch mal ein bisschen drin rumfuddeln ob ihr irgendwelche
großartigen bugs findet aber sollte erst mal so passen denke ich
Das war klar dass irgendwie einer mit dem rechten rand kommt und so nach dem wurde erst
mal klippen so nach dem motto guck mal was der wax wieder erzählt ohne kontext geht
es natürlich besser
Ohne Kontext lebt sich einfacher
Ja leute schön dass ihr am start wart
Wer es noch nicht hat kann mein 20 euro hetzner startgutschein einlesen
Gutschein für 20 euro startguthaben einlösen so rum
Wie sieht das server setup aus das kann ich jetzt noch mal kurz zeigen das server setup
ist easy as fuck ein load balancer für zertifikate und ssl terminierung und ein server dahinter
mit triple core cpu
Die natürlich unglaublich wichtig ist bei einer kleinzeitigen mini webseite da brauchst
du eine triple core kiste mit vier gigabyte ram um das hier auszuliefern das geht gar
nicht anders
Und diese triple core kiste könnt ihr beide mit meinem 20 euro startgutschein schon fast
drei monate laufen lassen
Übrigens auch noch eine andere sache die ganz interessant ist jetzt noch mal auf hetzner
start zurück zu kommen
Die haben jetzt mittlerweile wenn man versucht surfer anzulegen auch noch einen vierten
standort nämlich in den usa also wenn jemand irgendwas geo übergreifend anbieten will
hast zwei zwei also es einmal deutschland einmal findet und jetzt auch usa als standort
kakana time ja und vielleicht auch noch was man auch noch erwähnen sollte dieses load
balancer handling haben sie wirklich relativ easy gemacht was nimmst du als webserver das
ist eine node anwendung
Ich habe einen load balancer der kümmert sich um zertifikate ssl und er balanced auf
alle server die to do im tag haben das heißt wenn ich jetzt diese app noch fünf weitere
server dazustellen will ist das ganz einfach
fünf server anlegen über das kommando zeilen tun von hetzner oder übers web interface den
servern als tag to do geben und zack werden sie als backend im load balancer für diese
app verwendet
Und unter der haube ist es eine node.js app die da hinten rausfällt wenn man sfeld bild
macht aber da muss man die apps dafür programmieren
weil der unterschied zu einem normalen web framework ist ja die machen hier so einen
mischmash die rendern diese seite deswegen läuft die auch so schnell wenn ihr die lädt
die rendern diese seite auf dem server und übergeben das dann kleinzeitig an den browser
das heißt du hast initial schnelle ladezeiten und kannst aber alles machen was du kleinzeitig
machst und wenn du wissen willst in welchem state man sich gerade befindet kann man das
hier drüber abfragen also ist man hier in einem demo modus ist das glaube ich im browser
ist man environment modus oder ist man serverkat pre rendering base von der seite kann man
das statisch exportieren ja das kannst du statisch exportieren es gibt ein static es
gibt ein static exporter aber da funktionieren halt manche sachen nicht du kannst halt nicht
sagen ich möchte jetzt externe ressourcen laden während dem server seit rendering wenn
es kein server seit rendering gibt der logisch irgendwo da musst du halt das statisch rendern
an klein schicken und der klein muss dann erst mal zu allen möglichen apis gehen und
abfragen auf dem server könnte sein dass du das schon abgefragt hast und gecasht hast
für leute die öfters die seite aufrufen ja es gibt einen static adapter du kannst
es auch statisch rendern und du kannst es auch ein und ausschalten man kann hier irgendwie
sowas sagen wie export export prerendering oder sowas export prerendering gleich true
oder irgendwie sowas in der richtung ich kriege es aus dem kopf gerade nicht hin irgendwie
sowas kann man machen und dann checkt er ob er diese seite server seit vorrendern soll
oder nicht das eigentlich ziemlich clever gemacht muss man muss man mal wirklich sagen
das haben die welt leute wirklich exquisite gemacht heute ich sehe gerade ich war jetzt
viereinhalb stunden und ich habe quasi fast ein da übertrieben ein dreiviertel arbeitstag
gestreamt aber wir haben ja auch was ordentliches auf die reihe gekriegt ich meine für anbetracht
der tatsache dass ich absolut kein plan von svelte habe geschweige denn von tailwind kann
sich das doch jetzt für so als erste und ich mir gestern zum ersten mal angeguckt
habe kann sich das doch für so ersten versuch durchaus mal sehen lassen das der war grafiker
bei der new york times das wusste ich weiß nur ich weiß nur dass der das welt erfinde
heißt irgendwas mit harris glaube ich john hat ne richard harris oder so glaube ich irgendwie
so das weiß ich weil von dem habe ich letztens ein video dazu geguckt und darauf hin habe
ich mir gedacht das musste mal ausprobieren richtiger pfeiffer typ high high iq garantiert
leute wir sehen uns ich gehe jetzt mal aufs klo und was essen ich habe hunger wir sehen
uns bis dann macht's gut zu